oh you
[Music]
can perfect
[Music]
yo what's up guys i am thomas dopizzola
whatever you want to call me welcome
back to the dope as usual podcast we're
here to talk about life drugs problems
accomplishments and everything in
between i am here with marty o'neal
jurassic world what the [ __ ] is home
energy we've been doing [ __ ] all day
today guys let me just
let me just start new set behind this
wall just got built marty and i just
painted all [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of that
[ __ ] side we also painted this not
the not the designs just the white and
the black all right let's get this
straight yeah i don't think we're
[ __ ] tight we painted the black and
the white so that's a pretty smooth
black over there i like it the other
side's looking good i just looked it's
dry literally the paint's drying on the
other side of this wall is another room
we just soundproofed it this weekend and
it was loud as [ __ ] all weekend outside
and i didn't hear [ __ ]
so let's we're safe to say that our
soundproof worked we're actually going
to cut some holes in the wall this week
have the guy fill it with insulation and
sound proofing
set number two is coming
along very nicely for season two
i love walking in there when we walked
in after we painted we're like oh yeah
this this is it this is where it's
supposed to be yeah it's cool
having so much potential in front of it
yes like looking at the
base of it
just like we did with this yeah it's
just too hot guys and we've lasted all
summer and it's not even hot tonight we
just went through the hottest part of
the year and really the hottest it's
over here on earth
history
in a [ __ ] warehouse i dusted the
entire place out with a snowboard with a
leaf blower today so there's no dust in
here nice so i wait until we move yeah
yeah to dust the entire [ __ ]
warehouse
and there's
and it's not hot anymore anyway guys uh
we toughed it out that's what we film at
night it's [ __ ] 10 o'clock we film at
night because it's been so hot
it's so [ __ ] dusty because the
warehouse and there's wind outside we're
by the mountains and
it's just not it doesn't this place is
sick but you don't see the [ __ ]
sandstorm over there in the sky in the
warehouse and behind marty you can see
we put up new racks we got new shelving
push trees is expanding
and on that note the shirt i'm wearing
just peeled mmm i'm gonna go right into
it go right into it i'm [ __ ] pissed
i just emailed my manufacturers a
very long email with two
venting style
two venting videos like
so you know i i just paid you guys for
that uh yo it [ __ ] up what's going i
was i never mean even when you [ __ ] my
[ __ ] up i'm never like confrontational i
was just so [ __ ] mad i had to get it
out and
i paid a lot of money for this
everything on that rack back there guys
they did i haven't sold yet i've had for
five weeks because one of the items was
[ __ ] and i said i'm not releasing it
without everything
fix it so now they're fixing it i open
this shirt like the drop the drops in
two days
i made a new website
all right
i had my friend mike from shout out to
mike i've had my friend mike from merced
pick up those racks and drive them here
i paid him to drive him here then i get
that and half of the [ __ ] poles don't
even go to that section so i threw half
of them to somebody and they recycled
them i only ended up with one shelf i
bought two big out shells threw one away
essentially paid for it didn't even work
then it didn't fit because the ends of
the poles were bent so they wouldn't
slide together and hold so i had to go
get a hammer and pound out all of this
stuff
then i'm like yo it's too dirty had to
hire someone to come power wash it took
all the racks laid them out individually
had somebody power wash them
brought them in
put them on got the racks from you line
that go on doesn't even fit god i wish
we had the seinfeld thing on its own
my life is kirby enthusiasm guys they
don't even fit i got the racks early
this morning they're supposed to be here
friday i was like [ __ ] yeah i'm finally
gonna sleep the guy calls i'm outside
i'm on my way i [ __ ] i've been here
since this morning just literally did
you wait all day for the dude to power
wash yes that and then i went to the
doctor this morning and they're like oh
he's not even in the city anymore this
is a different office ankle surgery i go
oh my [ __ ] god i called him oh yeah
it's wrong on our website
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
so i left sorry from just complaining
and venting but this all happened today
within hours ago no this just happened
he has he turns the cameras on i changed
shirt i'm going to try the new [ __ ]
he started peeling are you [ __ ] with
me
the p came on uh if you ever bought push
trees closed and they've cracked
ah i did not know that's some [ __ ] i
go above and beyond to make sure that
[ __ ] don't crack i have five-year-old
shirts that's not cracked
so some [ __ ] cracks that's manufacturing
and i look like a dick
i have refunded so many people for crack
shirts from that one dude i ordered i
had to refund like two thousand dollars
worth of people out of my own [ __ ]
pocket and the shipping costs i lost
like four bands because this guy didn't
do a very good job never used them again
onto these people
they're good they did the bags they did
all my stuff that looks really good
and the simplest print of all time
started peeling
while you've been sitting around waiting
for them to correct yes and i've had
them for five weeks i've had the whole
order for five weeks but one of them was
messed up i go i'll wait till next month
to release it
built a brand new website went through
everything scramble to get those racks
yo you know how much i put into this
drop racks
literally rex and uh
i put a down payment house payment on
this [ __ ] on this order
and not one of them is usable i'm not
going to sell this i would not want
anybody to go [ __ ] thomas
the p started peeling so don't say that
don't please don't take this as you push
trees peels
no they don't crack we don't that's the
whole point like i'm not i'm not gonna
sell that i'll take these guys to court
before i [ __ ] you you're willing to go
through so much [ __ ] right now to not
not sell the [ __ ] i want my money back
you're like this feels like sandpaper
it's not [ __ ] weird this is not
glossed
why is it not glossed this is flea
market [ __ ] it looks really good but up
close don't like it anything that's ever
going to be on the site guys just
remember
it is past perfectionist [ __ ] yeah
hawkeye laser i'd describe it to people
like
anybody we're going to collaborate with
i'm like hey you better be honest think
he's like all stoned and [ __ ] but trust
me he sees [ __ ] that you don't see
through the hats i get tweezers bro i
get through tweezers i've gone through
thousands of hats with tweezers me and
rosie
taking off individual
lines of string that they leave on and i
don't i [ __ ] hate them it's like i
have ocd or some [ __ ] it's just being a
perfectionist about your brain yeah and
little pieces of string rosie and i have
done it for like nine hours straight
where we had a pile this big it doesn't
seem like a lot but of string yeah
of strings little baby strings
but making sure everything hitting it
with the lighter
tweezers cutting little scissors because
i don't want people to go look at this
string hanging out of this hat i bought
[ __ ] thomas i don't want that i
[ __ ] can't stand that
just got through that
what time is it how long have we been
how long we've been
about ten about time that was good [ __ ]
yeah i i always support letting [ __ ]
everybody know what you're gonna do
especially when it happens usually i
even said before we started like i
really wish i didn't check the shirt i'm
in a bad mood right now
i hate filming when i'm not like super
stoked
but i'm fine now i just had to get that
off my chest that [ __ ] really
it threw a wrench and everything sorry
guys the push tree strap will not be
releasing friday
that's all i'm gonna say i'll let you
guys know what sound board you about to
hit
what are you about to do to me
oh
[Music]
exactly when i was in the bathroom i
went oh
and i went
there's 1500 pieces in the warehouse
[ __ ] it just
because you guys gotta remember i hate
wasting [ __ ] so now these shirts nobody
gets to wear them
they just gotta go they're like [ __ ]
nobody gets to wear them did you have aj
right growing up like the slightly
[ __ ] [ __ ] up versions of the real
[ __ ] like they gotta go there
the [ __ ] is that aj what does that mean
aj right like all the clothes in there
are slightly defective oh it's a store
yeah it's called ross yeah we got that
out here yeah that's what we got out
here burlington coat factory in buffalo
is like nice [ __ ]
it might be the same [ __ ] thing it's
just different yeah but yeah the aj
right [ __ ] slightly defective that's
where
they can't sell this i don't give a
permission to resell this with my name
on it of course i'm just saying yeah
that's like all slightly [ __ ] up it's
a shame it's gotta go to waste yeah so
guys don't worry pushtrees.com none of
this is going on the [ __ ] site it
might look the same but it's gonna be
redone the right [ __ ] way
and i'm not paying a dollar for it i
want my [ __ ] money back
and then when they do it right i'll pay
them again
but as of now i want my house down
payment back it's been four months i've
been waiting on this order
sorry let's get on to something a little
better
pushtrees.com we got a bunch of cool
[ __ ] brand new website have you seen the
new site yeah i've seen glimpses and
samples they did a great [ __ ] job and
i love the photography the models and
everything model looks cool that dude is
dreadful he just fits well with our [ __ ]
i really like it sorry enough
complaining
guys this is year number eight push
trees and i'm still [ __ ] dealing with
this
still dealing with is there any version
of push trees where you own the
equipment and have employees running it
no
good mm-hmm it's so [ __ ] much too
much i'd rather just pay somebody that
does their job right i just want to pay
somebody that goes hey you're going to
do it right right
like when people give me the money to do
videos they go do whatever you want yeah
that's what i [ __ ] need yeah do your
[ __ ] bro here's the money it's you'd
think being out in l.a it wouldn't be
such a goddamn feat to try to find
somebody reliable that came out i won't
put it on blast but i told you the
brands that they do yeah they're
massive
are you [ __ ] my [ __ ] up
all right
my one color right one color it's the
first ever one color print
white
i have push three shirts from 2015 that
are still perfect
but this is fresh out the back peeling
oh my [ __ ] money back could about
[ __ ] 50 pack with that hmm
you're gonna get really pissed off you
started translating that [ __ ] the weed
match
we got a 50 pack of [ __ ] indoor with
that [ __ ]
here we go
sorry on to onto the show i just had to
get that off my chest god dude i would
have went for 45 minutes just repeating
myself
hulking out yeah mark marty said hey if
you're gonna collab with us and we're
doing something with you make sure
you're on your [ __ ] or you're gonna be
this motherfucker's calling marty that's
gonna be you
don't be that guy
we as long as you do your job well i'm
gonna [ __ ] pay you and then i'm gonna
go home
that's all i want
yeah that's all i need just do your job
that i paid you for
simple here we go simple yet eight years
into this business you're still [ __ ]
my last prayers are cool but they gave
me a run with new ink and it cracked
that's what i'm saying on the biggest
order i ever done up to that date and
wait guys i've been here for six years
and you're selling me a cracked cracking
shirts
well this relationship's over but
they're yeah they're
basically like yeah we're testing out
some new [ __ ] sorry and you're like well
that's my brain and my reputation [ __ ]
don't test your [ __ ] on me yeah i just
don't like people you all this full
cells cracked shirts that crack prints
suck like oh man you know how much
effort i go through to never hear that
just to hear that mm-hmm yeah well you
actually give a [ __ ] nine times out of
ten people aren't even [ __ ] seeing
the [ __ ] going out the door
you guys are hand packing
looking at every nuance of the tags and
the bags and i know i'm too i'm too anal
about it
but that i mean i don't want a string
sticking out of my [ __ ] tag make sure
it's perfect just how many millions of
street brands have come and gone i mean
you should have stuck around for a
reason yep for a [ __ ] reason
so that's where we're at right now guys
i'm super sorry i know i've been talking
about the push street drop for how many
episodes and it's not coming this week
just stay tuned pushtrees.com
push underscore trees underscore on
instagram that's our instagram i haven't
posted in like three weeks because i've
been waiting for all the pictures i just
got them
and now they're not i'm not gonna even
use them right now
on to the next thing
season two all right season two is
coming
we just hired a booking agent today
yeah that was that was the whole process
not a lot of booking agents out there oh
you got their wimpy what the [ __ ] this
is such a new industry but
yeah we got a couple hundred responses
and
narrowed it down about three people
and from there about two so we'll see
but it's one of those things it's not
like you can hire somebody for this
position and they just go do it we gotta
zipper them in for the next 90 days so
we had to put together a plan to
what would make sense to do that
and at the same time get you booked on
other podcasts
because just to put in perspective for
the fans kind of what you guys
we're at and where we want to be
going into season two
by season you know
this was our brand new this was getting
up and running getting our feet getting
our identity getting
to the point where we can be recognized
as a real podcast people want to go on
yeah by season three halfway through
season three we're the goal is to be
about triple
to
3.5 percent you know
over where we're at currently and then
really take off i know you're saying
triple but bro i know i'm being
overwhelmed
i'll be conservative because i know what
other people have done and i'm just like
if we could get there then we'd be super
straight and then there's touring and
not even that dude the last four weeks
we haven't five weeks we haven't really
been on the clips too hard on the [ __ ]
supposed to moving into his new house no
no
it's supposed to living in his nose yeah
that's stuck in a room it seems like a
long drawn out process from the fire
yeah so he's trying to type while caring
about three kids like
every time i call something's happening
or someone's hanging off you we're
really and he's like
typing
yes and he's typing so it's like
stressful as soon as we get back and
already lost the keys to us oh we talked
about this last time yeah but i found
him finally [ __ ] today today
back in that [ __ ] office i'm gonna
start cranking out some cool online
content too
yeah it's gonna be cool i'm really
excited i'm i've never been more
motivated before i really same bro i
just
i just need things to start circulating
i just want people to work as hard as i
do and it's not gonna [ __ ] happen
so i need people any times too so you
guys can work half as hard and get the
job done or something
i just you already know you already know
sorry damn
[ __ ] really pissed me off
sorry here we go let's get into this
[ __ ] story i mean this episode
marty and i like i said have been
painting all day so i've been putting
marty up on all these new crazy ass
shows i've been watching
guys i know we don't get into this often
you know what
let me talk about the most exciting part
so
you guys let me tell you a little story
when i was about 16 years old
i was laying on my grandpa's couch on
the left side of the living room
i saw the show come on
fx
and this guy comes in and it's automatic
racism jokes and i went
what is this offensive show
there's this offensive hysterical thing
that i just witnessed
and then the intro started and you know
they're showing background shots of of
philadelphia
and all this [ __ ] happens then they're
at a bar and i'm like what is this show
it's always stunning in philadelphia is
the show i'm talking about i
accidentally stumbled upon it the first
premiere night on fx
alright season one
you guys know how much i love movies and
love filming i just love seeing the act
whenever i see a movie truck like parked
on the side with generators i know
someone's filming like a movie i just
get hyped i get excited like oh my god
[ __ ] yeah they're velvet i just love it
so
i called marty tonight two days ago
because i come outside
and outside of my warehouse
there's a huge semi-trailer
and then another one and they have all
the we're filming things we're in
burbank right there's like a warehouse
right here next to the street
i see people film all the time like we
talked about the blue johnson podcast
notoriously it just dropped right
through us yeah we just i drove through
the set by accident right
that place it's i won't say we're at on
birmingham i want you know where exactly
we're at in burbank but
anyway
i look gonna go
that's three semi trucks
this is a movie they're filming a
[ __ ] movie on the block holy [ __ ]
nice
i see more then i see the [ __ ] pa
people when i see the [ __ ] taco truck
and the food truck and then the extras
tent
and then the talent trailer i'm like
what's being filmed here oh [ __ ] i leave
i come back and one security guards
parked in my [ __ ] parking space i'm
like yo get the [ __ ] out of my space but
politely
and as he backs up i'm like walking on
the side of the building just to look at
the trailer because it's a sick sick
production trailer
i'm like an always sunny philadelphia
poster oh another one like yo they must
work on that show this is so tight i'm
just hyped
i started walking back to the warehouse
door and i look at the security guard
and go
are they filming it's always stunning in
philadelphia right here he goes yeah
yeah we just started
i [ __ ] exploded into the sky i talked
to the man for 30 seconds and he didn't
give a [ __ ]
no i went no [ __ ] way i was on the
phone with you
i was on facetime with you huh start
going all trivial
i lost my [ __ ] like wait
you're telling me you're filming it's
always sunny right here are you [ __ ]
kidding me
so they've been filming for three days
outside i saw [ __ ] d day one
i saw [ __ ] d reynolds standing
outside the [ __ ] food truck
and i saw like oh my god as i'm packing
push trees orders
oh while i was putting these these
these uh poles together
i was just looking out the door i left
the door and the roll-up door open just
so i can see like i'm just taking my
time never been done before
yeah yeah exactly just packing orders
while looking like i'm just look i'm
gonna see one of them and i'm gonna go
yeah i love you
just because you guys know i'm a [ __ ]
fanatic for always sunny i mean i have
danny devito
picture in my office well it's not in
the office not in the office anymore as
soon as i found out with marty i took it
and put it by the door and marty gave me
a marker in case i see one of them i'll
walk outside like yo this is in my
office could you sign this [ __ ] thank
you for making me laugh for 15 [ __ ]
years and um
i haven't seen anybody else i just it's
literally where me and marty were
painting the set i was just
you kept looking i didn't realize you
were so honest i was looking every time
i heard a car saw something i was just
yeah you told the security guard they
come out here i'm running out here don't
get scared bro but i'm gonna come out
here with my sign i'm gonna [ __ ] lose
my [ __ ] so
just letting you know it's my building
but you're sitting in front of the
building yeah i'm going to lose my [ __ ]
and come out here just don't don't try
to stop me basically technically you're
my security guard right now
you're guarding my building you're i
don't know why they just sit them right
in front of our door which is like what
if i'm a business that would piss me off
but they're nice
anyway
um then we go out to home uh where do we
go we
we're about to walk
oh we're gonna get drinks we're gonna
walk there's a little store i'm trying
not to i'm trying to be kind of vague
and we're at but there's a little liquor
store by us
we're going to get it or get uh drinks
and i walk by and by the set there's a
limo
and i'm like wait
i just saw mac
post something
uh holy [ __ ] is this the [ __ ] thing
in the episode and it's kind of a ripped
up limo i'm like no
way and i look in the window
and there's a sign on the seat
for phil it's always stunning in
philadelphia and then a script on the
seat
of the limo and i just saw it like oh my
[ __ ] god guys i i love that [ __ ] i
know like i'm not gonna go oh my god
freak out in front of i'm just gonna
like internally like that you were doing
that on the inside yeah for sure
you know i love filming i love all that
[ __ ] max started that show
they had no budget i know everything
about that [ __ ] i told you i told you
all of it today just yeah they had no
budget
i love them so [ __ ] much i love that
show so severely
that when i saw that they're i mean
outside the window you can see the
always sunny [ __ ] promo posters
that's so weird what are the odds
it's [ __ ] crazy it made my day
my back
by way of their generation yeah they had
a generator outside for their trailers
and it was right outside the window and
you couldn't really hear it in our room
it's working the set soundproofed i'll
say this that's pretty sound improved
guys yeah my joint went out
anyway
i'm just so [ __ ] excited
i'm gonna see one of i mean i saw d but
i'm not gonna rush her
i'm gonna see one of these [ __ ]
outside and i'm good thanks for the
laughs [ __ ] i'm gonna walk back
near the warehouse
and then i'll make you guys laugh or
something else i don't know like trickle
down comedy thanks bro
but um yeah sorry for the long rant
always sunny is being filmed outside the
warehouse right now and i tomorrow's a
lot i know everything about this filming
i asked the security guard like so it's
till thursday
yeah yeah you know coming here blah blah
blah and i knew when this cast got there
because they blacked out the back of the
building so you couldn't see because
before i could see straight in
and i can see all the crew guys i'm so
excited you guys know you guys know how
excited i am
it's right outside the set like holy
[ __ ]
so happy so i mean my shirt's appealing
but always sunny is outside so
i'll take it i'll take it
follow me a lot of good [ __ ] going on
i was all ignorant i'm thinking i'm like
oh
[ __ ] you're like i'm explaining the show
he goes doesn't somebody have aids in
that movie you go
the [ __ ] is wrong with you he's like
thomas
i mean philadelphia
the movie from the [ __ ] 90s another
movie i haven't seen philadelphia i was
like you know what you mean we was
banging antonio banderas
no that is not always sunny in
philadelphia marty that's not the show
i'm talking about
yo i love this aids movie
i have a picture of [ __ ] harvey milk
and [ __ ] like no no
that's not what it's
it's danny devito and a wig glad we
cleared that up yeah i had no i didn't
even know that's what that was from oh
yeah
you thought that was about [ __ ] ace
never connected that [ __ ] i mean
that was right there you go there's that
show about eight
no it's not bro well i guess it could be
if you want it depends on what you i'm
gonna watch i'm gonna go home and watch
it
i have every season guys but the new one
anyway
oh real quick paddy's pub if you're a
fan paddy's pub is on third and mateo
downtown
that sounds like a good roar kinda i
slap my sticker up in front because the
bar so we use it for the set
i slapped a push tree sticker on the
paddy's pub stop sign
and in season 13 when mac's outside all
buff you can see the push trees logo
right behind his [ __ ] head
and me and rosie were watching the
premiere and you know i jumped to the
ceiling
mortal kombat [ __ ] i went to the next
level lost my [ __ ]
i couldn't [ __ ] believe it
you could see our logo right behind max
head season 13
right here
oh [ __ ] no
i'm surprised
they let that end
i think they forgot because they clean
them all the time and i slap them every
time i stop i just slap a new one
[ __ ] that every time slapping a new one
um but yeah
super cool i went inside there it's not
even paddy's pub they have art shows
there
that was kind of this boy i know i'm not
in tune with
a lot of all the movie references from
the 80s and 90s even like the office
all that i got to go back and watch all
this also i remember i told you earlier
i remember everything so it's hard for
me to watch
not comedies over and over because like
i already know everything that's gonna
happen but in comedies you know what's
gonna happen it's funny so you watch it
again i don't want to
watch tommy die of aids again in
philadelphia you know you need to see
that once or twice and it's pretty much
over yeah you get that you guys you guys
know what we're talking about
how much time are we in
20 okay okay this time i really think
we're going to keep it an hour and a
half we'll see we'll see last episode
was an hour and a half that show was
there near my favorite episode yeah the
last boo johnson episode i [ __ ] love
that dude yeah he is so damn cool and
straight motivational
everything about the guy is like just
disciplined but fun
perfect perfect
sounds great mm-hmm
loved it yeah i mean that's the episode
overt positive vibes just by being a
cool ass dude you're so chill
that's like leading by example because
you got people that go out that are like
motivational and they don't do it
they're trying to tell you they're like
they're overtly motivational there's
other people that you just
you're inspired by who they are yeah
he was mad mad cool on and off gamer he
was cool as [ __ ] so shout out to boo
johnson shout out to you guys for
listening last week
yeah
i'm not even
before all this i wasn't in tune with
the skateboard world at all and now i'm
starting to really realize like how much
of a mainstream not mainstream but just
how big of a thing it is to people even
like we're i was telling you the dude
that's gonna paint our set i mentioned
yeah we just had blue johnson on he's
like [ __ ] boo johnson i grew up on
that floor there's a bunch of people
that reacted like that
that like just like we were saying
street ball and one basketball all that
is like we're explaining people yeah
you're like why is it so bingo
you loved hot sauce man one
it's the same love like yo that feels so
sick
and you play basketball you like it some
people skate and they look at this fool
like what the [ __ ] this fool does it
like nothing
his little lines he does
he's just smooth and [ __ ] it's just
it's a style
that makes you stand out and he's got
that for sure
um
yeah so let's see we can keep us an hour
and a half guys let's stay on this topic
of watching [ __ ] just because i have
been what rosie's been sick for a week
rosie's got r.a like rheumatoid
arthritis so she had a flare-up
she's never had one she's been together
i've never had one she's never had one
before
she's been [ __ ] sick for a week
and she's finally getting better so when
i'm home i just been watching [ __ ] with
her because she doesn't want to [ __ ]
do anything she feels like [ __ ]
so we watched some crazy [ __ ] all right
now watch some [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] i'm gonna
get into all of them and i suggest that
you go check them out
i'm not gonna suggest some [ __ ] to
you i would never do that to you
like my friend tyler you [ __ ]
tyler i [ __ ] hate you he always like
you should watch the show called love on
the spectrum and i watch them go you
piece of [ __ ] i don't want to watch
exploited [ __ ] down syndrome people
this is [ __ ] love on the spectrum is
people with autism
and it's a dating show
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then he's like you should watch life
after lockup and i'm like yo it sounds
terrible and i watched two full [ __ ]
seasons of it feeling like a piece of
[ __ ]
for putting my time and energy i was
typing and editing but still i'm like
it's if you know life after lockup
i [ __ ] it it follows all right cool
april's never met you you've been in
prison for five years she's dating you
got married in prison now you're getting
out they're following your life and how
it is it doesn't work out but they're
following your life yeah some of these
girls are so [ __ ] stupid some of
these dudes are so [ __ ] dumb falling
for these people in prison
and they're obviously being played
putting these people before their kids
and this and moving it's like
did you guys follow my mom did you guys
you guys know my mom
have you ever met my mom before because
this
the reason i hate the show because i'm
like
that little kid's me
that little kid in that scene that in
that group that's me watching my mom
make these terrible decisions going to
corcoran
prison every weekend to visit
that's my mom
there's other dudes
that's the things like yo there's other
people why do you guys just stuck on
these prisoners he's different but
bitchy's not and things are interviewing
the guy and the girl whether she's in
prison he's in prison i know i'm fully
explaining i'm explaining a horrible
show to you sorry i'm not suggesting
this [ __ ] do not watch it unless
you're a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] like i
was
breaking this down so they don't have to
watch it breaking it down
but the guy's like oh no i don't really
love this bid
and the girl's like we're getting
married
and the guy in prison has three other
[ __ ] waiting on him yeah or vice
versa yeah and you're watching going do
you really you believe that man ah
and then i go mom
ugh it makes me so i know you're
watching this too and you're in the chat
hey man it's okay to say you were a
[ __ ] idiot from like 30 to 40. it's
fine
you were dating that stupid [ __ ]
you know you don't have to date white
supremacists he
was it one inmate or was she dating
multiple and it's like 15 different
stories
they followed different people no no i'm
talking about your ma
oh just one guy okay so she wasn't oh no
no no i'm saying the decisions like oh
uh he's going to go for three years oh
i'll be there every weekend in writing
and putting money on your books like
[ __ ] i'm hungry yeah
we don't do school projects because we
don't have money but he's got money on
his
[ __ ] you that's how i always felt
but who gives a [ __ ] anyway do not watch
that show [ __ ] you for making that show
ready yup and my friend
tyler i hate your your decisions i hate
you so much for [ __ ] in a funny way i
hate you having fun don't watch love on
the spectrum there's exploiting people
with that autism and downs of german
[ __ ]
no thanks
no thank you yeah that's the that's
something it's two people that have the
same illness and they're dating but it
always is this
hey what's up oh hey it's like yo
they're they're autistic they don't talk
that's the [ __ ] illness they have
socially [ __ ]
so it's like it's watching two people be
not comfortable
and it's just exploitation and it makes
me feel bad
that's why i will not watch that show
but i love on the spectrum rosie's
watching her
live after lock i'm like rosie i hate
you for watching this all right put the
next episode on [ __ ] i gotta know what
this [ __ ] does [ __ ] 14 episodes later
[ __ ]
i'm i'm done i will never do it again on
to some good [ __ ] all right that was dog
[ __ ] tv
and if you watch like that honey boo boo
[ __ ] that those shows are for you
you're the reason that these are one of
those 10 billion people out there
watching that [ __ ] yep you're one of the
reasons why that idiocracy is coming
true have you ever seen a movie
idiocracy
you know from now on i'ma stop asking
you have you and say hey you should
watch thank you today
i spit out like 30 gems and you go never
seen it
yeah
i'm like if it was before 96 and it
wasn't [ __ ] goonies i probably didn't
see that [ __ ] we didn't watch movies
now that i know you're dynamic with your
family you guys never watch movies mama
real quick story the movie very bad
things boom probably on the screen movie
with very bad things with christian
slater and
daniel stern farva and [ __ ] jeremy
piven
great movie
super [ __ ] up dark humor
watched at about seven
it was a good movie me and my mom my
sister watched it great this is back
because he asked me do you guys have
blockbusters oh yeah we have blockbuster
hollywood video and this [ __ ] mom and
pop rental the mom and popper and i told
you had a curtain over one of the aisles
and this is set xxx and i was like what
is that aisle
i'm like six or seven
i know it's bad because there's a
curtain over it i see creeps coming out
of there
could you imagine how [ __ ] creepy you
really was before the internet every
[ __ ] person oh my god
going in there with you everybody was
not even that they got a return that's
what i'm saying you're going and you're
all on the boxes with it oh god
no thanks
and uh
the movie very bad things we had
watching before my mom like i said this
is one of the nights that where she was
like yo let's do stuff so we're going to
watch a movie make popcorn my mom says
let's watch that movie again the very
bad things and go cool let's read a
bunch of other ones blah blah blah
it's got to be their fault because why
was
here we go we're at the checkout stand
you know beep
oh let me get the movie get set and put
it in this is a cassette it's not a dvd
and he gets the very bad things he beats
it and he goes
you got this on this the one you want it
looks at my mom two kids my sister
little me
mom
here's the guy i'm the cashier you sure
this is what you want and my mom says
yeah she goes
this is not this is a bad movie and she
goes i know we've seen it before and he
just like
gave my mom like oh
and she looked at him like they've seen
the movie we watched it together and he
goes you've watched this with them
and the guy was like judging my [ __ ]
mom for letting us watch the movie
internally and i went yeah i've seen it
before it was good and the k the guy
looks at me like
you've watched this r r-rated movie with
death in it that's the looking vibe my
mom's like yes we've seen it just give
me the movie we get home
30 seconds in we realized that this man
was
appalled because it was very bad things
the porno
not very bad things the funny dark humor
comedy with jeremy piven in it
it starts and there's people just
[ __ ] on camera all right i just see
naked bodies and people moving i go ah
and my mom goes what the [ __ ] takes it
out and looks it says very bad things
and it has like a subtitle in his porn
title
so the guy's like you've watched this
with them that's why he was looking at
us like what the [ __ ]
he thought my mom was a pedophile she's
not she somebody at the store put the
very bad things in the wrong thing
that's all it was they put he got like
the wrong case that's all it was
because back then they didn't have like
you remember how it was back then some
of them were just blank
cassette boxes and then you go up to the
front and they put it in there and they
give you the sleeve yeah
for all of you they didn't know about
that that's how you used to get movies
and uh
yeah that's the time my mom rented porn
for us it's really [ __ ] funny christ
that dude's a creep for giving your mom
that movie no he questioned her multiple
times like
you watch this they've watched that
that's how he looked like
oh
so he wasn't a creep i think he was
appalled at this woman and i was young
my mom was like 20 [ __ ] three jesus
christ 24 she was a young lady it looked
like their older sister probably or
something i don't know what was going on
but that happened
anyway i don't know how we got into that
topic oh yeah i gotta stop asking about
movies because i was like oh you guys
watch movies together you're like
she just did drugs in that room so we
watch movies in this room like hey pay
attention to that [ __ ]
so you know about every [ __ ] movie
the cable guy yeah before phones this is
before phones i'm reading the back of
movie cases
watching everything the four nf
memorizing the credits watching the
credits oh for sure and i never
understood what key grip meant best boy
best grip dolly my whole life i never
got what it meant
until i started filming and people told
me what that's what best grip means or
key grip yeah i just never i never
understood it
yeah i really
yeah anyway uh let's get on to this i
know it's a long rant here we go here we
go here we go
i wanted to keep this a little different
this episode i wanted to not talk about
so many stories and just talk about
what's been going on yeah yeah it was
good yeah yeah
so here we go here we go here we go we
need some like intro music to bring in
ourselves to bring in our segments
going across the screen or a little
dude running with a flag across the
screen what's good
can we do that i'm sure if i green
screen myself oh yeah you can do that of
course we should do that i have somebody
that has a full green screen wall i know
so
we should do that i would love it if i
stopped stop
i kept running with a [ __ ] flag
what's good
i'm worth it okay okay season two here
we go it's not for everybody it's not
for everybody
i [ __ ] love that
let me give my dad the sticker but you
remember
yeah
guys uh like i said rosie was sick been
watching a bunch of [ __ ]
let's start let's start not in any order
so there's a movie called a show called
squid games and it's on netflix i
believe
it's an all korean on korean the second
it started ago so this is like battle
royale if you don't know what battle
royale is i think it's japanese
it's a [ __ ] up movie battle royale is
crazy wild as [ __ ]
and um it's about some high school class
that has to fight to the death and it's
a law in their country
battle royale yeah that shit's wild
you're seeing kill bill yeah it looks
like there's a kill bill graphic kill
bill gore
blood oh it is the chick from guild bill
the girl with the spike ball at the
bottom yeah yeah
yeah it came out 000
it's a great movie if you have time go
watch battle royale if you don't care
about subtitles it's a great movie
anyway
squid games [ __ ]
me up that [ __ ] was
awful you know like
not like bad film or bad writing i don't
like seeing people get hurt or [ __ ] up
it's just i don't like it
if you don't like that either do not
watch the show but this show is [ __ ]
good man i'm just sitting there reading
korean subtitles
before the booty
[ __ ] what did this rewind it i i have to
read it i missed the [ __ ] subtitle
you know what i mean like hey can you
rewind it again
it's a shot really [ __ ] well
the set design the designs are so hard
so tight i don't want
okay it's a game the show is about a
game that people willingly play
can you could possibly die while playing
that's all i'm going to give you i don't
want to tell you anymore because then
i'm going to [ __ ] it up
it's it's it's [ __ ] up it's whoever
this is like on some
saw meets
names
well hunger games is a ripoff of battle
royale though okay white people battle
royales games yeah that's fair uh cause
they just did like hey let's get some
american actors to steal this concept
that's how i feel i've never watched
hunger games saw the preview went
that's battle royale i'm out and that
was pretty much it
and uh
squid games go check it out guys go
check it out it was really good i think
it's only like 10 or 12 episodes
good [ __ ] all right shout out to whoever
that guy that guy's a good [ __ ] actor
the second to the right the guy smiling
with the purple background
good [ __ ] i would like to see him in
something
you
oh gong oh that's him
that's his name oh no that's a different
actor uh different actor but it's all
good
everybody the show is great everybody
did a good job super believable
i like it
so that's something you got to see squid
games right
on to my next one we won't talk about it
but this is gonna
marty this is a little wild
nine perfect strangers all right guys
not wait did we talk about snowfall on
this show
i don't know i don't remember i think we
did that so we did with rick ross
no we did the college episode um about
rick ross
i don't know we did we did talk about uh
we met the dude right mm-hmm
i don't [ __ ] remember i don't
remember talking too much
so i know we talk on the phone too much
is what it is
[ __ ] i gotta start making notes like
talk about this on the podcast
anyway let's go night perfect strangers
such a good show like a really good good
good well thought out show
the intro might be the best intro i've
seen in any show i love the [ __ ]
intro so much it is it just feels like
drugs
i feel like i'm about to start peaking
it's a great show
uh
right there
the guy on the left the guy that was in
take shelter the white dude with the
glasses that's one of my favorite i
can't remember his name but he's such a
good [ __ ] actor dude
what is his name he's so damn good
oh michael shannon michael shannon why
did i forget his name he's you really
know people's [ __ ] names i don't know
i forgot his name he's really [ __ ]
good actor man but in this one this one
is about i will tell you a little bit
it's about
trying to talk to the afterlife
but
insanely
psychedelic induced hmm
bro
whoa
i just one of the few shows i watched
when it came out by week and i was like
[ __ ] no i'm gonna wait a week to watch
this [ __ ] [ __ ] this movie or [ __ ] this
show and i'm still there every next week
just to watch it
guys highly suggest you go watch night
perfect strangers it was really [ __ ]
good
every single actor did a good job
and i'll point out when people like uh
it was okay the acting was a little bit
everybody did a good job even the vine
kid that black dude that's the kid from
vine that i pointed out where we're
hanging out with those dudes and i go
and he goes hey
that's uh
he goes hey i direct the or i'm on the
snowfall or whatever he's on snowfall
he's
he started off on vine the same time i
started off on vine bro i was telling
you yeah except he didn't go the weed
right he came like the world star funny
route and now he's on [ __ ] huge show
did a good job dude he did a good job i
liked it it was all good everything was
good
i haven't really been seeing a lot of
[ __ ] that i'm like yo writing directing
feeling oh bomb
[ __ ] yeah you [ __ ] with it i really like
it and for everybody in the comments
saying yeah i loved it i loved it too
nine
characters there's a lot of people to
[ __ ] to take care of
they did it perfect
love the show
super good and it's one [ __ ] season
done
and that's a
they wrapped the whole thing up in one
season i love that also vice principles
is not on my list but
vice principles is one or two seasons
it's with danny mcbride
and the other dude i can't remember he's
in so many things he's so [ __ ] good
uh he's such a good actor that dude on
the right on the top right there i can't
remember his name he's such a good actor
is it really his name
yeah
oh that that's him great actor dude he's
so good he's so [ __ ] good anyway vice
principals is only one or two seasons
and it's so [ __ ] good
it's [ __ ] hilarious i love this
[ __ ] poster it's so funny dude i
think it's like four or five years old
but it's it's such a good show talking
about one season and done nine perfect
strangers go watch that i feel like i
just talking to you on the facetime
right now and we're not even doing a
show [ __ ]
because i'm so used to like hitting
[ __ ] topic topic topic telling me
what the washing [ __ ] yeah but now it's
like yo
yeah okay here we go
i exposed marty to t grizzly today
uh-huh
my phone's wild
[ __ ] wild and i put him on to
mob trial one mob figures
hmm that was a good album oh yeah um
okay it's not imperfect stranger squid
games and we have not talked about
snowfall yet we were talking about that
on a vlog are you guys ready
i've been watching snowfall we had rick
ross freeway rick ross on the show not
too long ago
one of the main franklin if you watch
snowfall franklin's based off of rick
ross
they stole his identity again bro
i'm sorry the simulators the
similarities are so
so
sim it's
similar like the simulators are crazy
right
anyway snowfall is a great [ __ ] show
they do such a good job
with character build up on there's like
five four different stories they're
following but they all like a crash like
i told you they all connect somehow
it's about rick ross i mean talk about
nicaragua with cia [ __ ] contra war
about the kids selling rocks and [ __ ]
south central rick ross
i mean franklin the real franklin was
literally just on our show two weeks ago
and it's [ __ ] crazy to think about
how awesome that guy was
he's still more cracking anybody on the
planet
damn
[ __ ] i can't wait time to come back
that was great i love that [ __ ]
episode yeah for sure we've been so
interesting dude great guys come on yeah
we have man um
sorry snowfall marty and i went to one
of marty's friends as a movie producer
we went to he invited us to go you know
watch football hang out stuff like that
so we're sitting there and it's one of
those hangouts where you're like oh
everyone in this room is invited for a
reason yeah it's not just oh it's coming
it was more of like
every one of you guys is producing
something everyone uses something
something we should all talk you should
all talk to you
what did it what's the one similar
question that everybody asked you
can you
think of it
like what's one question that every
single person that you talk to that
night asked you what do you do besides
that
i don't know
i won't say his name how do you know
oh yeah yeah cause he was the one that i
get that but
every single person i talked to that was
the first question they asked so how did
you know this this guy the guy i'm
talking i want to say his name but how
do you know so-and-so every single
[ __ ] person is the first thing they
ask me
you guys network a lot huh yeah i don't
i would have been like so what's up man
you want to hit this
like i don't do that i'm not good with
that because i never think about
business [ __ ] i'm always like
just chill and do my own thing but after
watching all those guys like this is how
i want to hang out i only want to hang
out to network and [ __ ] do business
and go home
i don't want to sit around and just sit
because that's time while spending time
it really was i love being in that
circle like you produce what i was
talking about that white kid with the
long hair he's a [ __ ] movie pretty i
won't say it but he's been producing
movies and [ __ ] he started off as a
receptionist at a [ __ ] production
company
like nine years ago
dude and he's telling me all these
things he does yeah i get the casting
done do this i'm like so tell me what
you do and i had to ask like what do you
do as a movie producer
and then we're just talking everybody in
the room does something i knew i
recognized that one guy i'm looking at
him like i've seen you on some show i
just don't remember and somebody told me
i'm like ah the csi show i knew that was
this guy and uh
so we're sitting there and just talking
to everybody everybody's so [ __ ]
chill that's the one thing i really
liked like everybody was chill the dude
from chicago
roy i think his name was i was one of
those they live sharing he goes hey yeah
they live i did roddy piper's last
interview ever bro i [ __ ] did a
documentary on him and we talked for an
hour like
what just take a [ __ ] seat bro and
then he's like what do you do that was a
good idea wearing that shirt to that
[ __ ] that and i just knew somebody was
gonna be like
so you know they live like yeah what's
up
what movies do you [ __ ] with yeah
because that's my thing like
you like that movie we would probably be
friends mm-hmm you know what i'm saying
but he's like yeah i did the last i'm
like he's like so when it comes out i'll
let you guys know it's
so
and
every everybody was just so shocked what
do you do
how do i say this
well marty and i right there we do a
podcast blah blah blah what's it about
it's drugs and stuff i hit people i
slammed them with the with the slogan
when they asked that now
yeah i say it like i'm just thinking it
yeah accomplishment everybody loves it
it's perfect yeah it wraps we made that
up seconds before we started remember
this is about and i just flirted it and
it [ __ ] stuck in my head and i wrote
it down i loved it
um
anyway go back to the party we're
talking and that kid
from the nine perfect strangers the kid
from vine i just showed you
the black guy he's on snowfall and he
pops up on a commercial i go damn
this motherfucker's crushing it from
vine to this
i love it good job bro you stepped it
into something else
you did what 99.9 of people do not and
cannot do right and he did a good job of
it and i guarantee he'll be around for a
while just based off the characters he
played
you know i mean like
[ __ ] r.i.p michael k williams [ __ ]
playing omar on the wire you got to
watch the [ __ ] wire he's forever to
me that's oh that's omar you ever hear
conway the machine always reference omar
and then [ __ ] that's who he's talking
about
because he only robbed drug dealers in
the show and when he walked down the
block the drug deal would be like [ __ ]
throw their bag out the window like take
it bro
we don't want no [ __ ] problems with
this guy he walks around two shotguns
sup
kicks the door and robs these drug deal
is that [ __ ] that's his job that's what
he's known for in that show like
that's omar mm-hmm when he called with
him omar throw the bags out the window
that's where the talk is they're like
nah omar's here i don't want anything to
do with him just give him the [ __ ]
money for the day
that's how ever he walked down the block
and everybody's throwing backs out the
window
he's just looking
don't want it all right
like
nobody wants a piece of that [ __ ] guy
you know they could have popped him from
the window
he was like the devil mm-hmm no i know i
know that dude
oh yes yes you don't shoot at him like
oh yeah you say he hasn't seen the usual
suspects but what happens if you shoot
the devil in the back what if i missed
that's the kevin spacey line
how do you shoot the devil in the back
what if i missed
because in that he has a crippled hand
oh my god it's a good movie too bad he's
a rapist [ __ ]
i can't believe kevin spacey got
convicted of doing that wild [ __ ] we'll
not talk about that because youtube is
going to be weird uh let's continue
anyway snowfall damn we rant
sorry anyway yeah speaking of youtube
also sorry we had to change the title of
the last [ __ ] episode yeah dmt trips
and hardflips youtube
took our monetization off i changed it
to always grinding turned it right back
on
yeah they're just going hey are you sure
you want to do that
are you sure you want to say that
no they can say it not you though [ __ ]
no rogan yeah no joe rogan he can talk
about it all day probably do it on the
show but not you
those are adult letters that aren't
allowed in your channel
it might
god knows what might happen i mean vice
shows crack being cooked
there's a million rap songs with coke
bricks in it so [ __ ] you and we got a
guy talking about positivity the most
amazing
journey of his life and he got age
restricted all right i got demonetized
instantly i changed it seconds later
went back on
that's why we changed the title so back
to this guys uh we're we're still at the
guys watching football talking all these
movie dudes they're all cool and that
guy pops up on tv and i go and i start
telling you out loud to go marty that's
the guy from vine i told you about he's
in [ __ ] nightmare for strangers he's
a snowfall he's crushing it
and the little mexican dude goes
oh sick bro you watch snowfall i go yeah
man i [ __ ] love you i'm on season
four episode eight goes
i edit that i added snow falls like i'm
the sound engineer i edit like all the
sound i go what cause yeah like you hear
money hitting the table or somebody gets
stabbed like that's me i'm doing all the
[ __ ] he's on the editor you're not
supposed to notice and i like things he
said i love that i'm the editor you're
not supposed to know that's there nobody
i can love you for saying that nobody
draws attention enough to that nope you
know he did a phenomenal job when you
never even never knew he thought
yes exactly and he's like yeah i just i
mix it i'm the guy that does the sound
blah blah blah he's like we just uh
wrapped up episode two today
of season five like yo
i'm on season four episode eight
don't i was like don't tell me nothing i
even told my don't say nothing listen
i'm not even done yet like i'm going to
get some inside no but i'm like don't
say [ __ ] don't say nothing all right man
i haven't finished the season and then
um
but okay again buy the [ __ ] warehouse
because we're in burbank and there's a
spot there's a warehouse they use it in
snowfall a lot so every time in snowfall
go wait
the warehouse is right [ __ ] behind
this and then they showed a shotgun bro
that's the [ __ ] warehouse now season
one
so we weren't even in this building yet
you know it's four years ago we weren't
even here yet but season four we were in
this building
so that means like we were in this room
and it's right in the back of the
snowfall shot like oh [ __ ] yeah it's so
[ __ ] cool to me i love that [ __ ]
i know you guys are you're [ __ ]
fanning out geek i love filming i love
it so much i don't give a [ __ ] like
danny devito
yeah and i'm gonna go about my day and
start editing and [ __ ] do the
uh that's done i just for me to go [ __ ]
yeah it's crazy that like we record our
show in the same zone as all these
[ __ ] big shows yeah dude
45 yards right there there's vito and
[ __ ] dennis reynolds and all these
guys they're there right now phil yeah
here we are security guards are outside
right now we're just smoking weed
and they're filming season 15 always
sunny [ __ ] yards away i can't
it's
my brain's gonna pop
i can't [ __ ] handle it life is coming
full circle i love it so much i love it
so much dude
i'm not even part of it and i love it so
much um
so the guy's like yeah i [ __ ] do the
editing go bro
sick
like yo i love that and he goes i got my
start because i edited the season uh the
first narcos the first season of narcos
i go whoa [ __ ]
yeah that's like yeah i got
kind of got my name out there like yeah
yeah bro you were you were the guy on
narcos you're the [ __ ] engineer the
sound guy
not like the guy holding the mic he's
the guy getting the [ __ ] and going
all right when he gets dad i know i want
this sound alright cool boom boom all
right we'll do this all right cool layer
it
he's the production
he's the guy that sees the show before
you do he's the reason that the show
sounds like
top not that i just love it i love that
unsung hero shift love it just it makes
a whole difference that sounds it's
people like that that have super long
successful careers
you know like he's not the actor he's
not the star of the show but he'll work
on
50 shows yeah you know the what was it
called the narco [ __ ] and then this [ __ ]
he's like
narcos mexico was cool
i liked it he was like but i think ours
is better because i know
that's how i feel i would feel the same
way i'm like i think i did better but
yeah but if i didn't i would say like
nah they they crushed it they did better
than me i need to step my [ __ ] up i'm
never afraid to admit that
but yeah it was very cool anyway
all the snowfall [ __ ]
then what a week or two ago i come back
come into the warehouse
and next door the building next door
it's a whole [ __ ] film team i told
you there's a whole film team outside
and i'm looking at them like that is an
old school 90s la bus
are they filming [ __ ] snowfall right
here because they film snowfall on this
block all the [ __ ] time go bro
is this a [ __ ] sea for snowfall i'm
seeing because i'm looking there and
they're setting up all this props and
shim like
old la bus prop
in the back and right here just gates
and and field and uh trees
so it looks like it could be any time it
could be the 90s 80s and 70s doesn't
matter trees don't have an eight i mean
like
you can't dress up a tree to be like
that's an 80s tree yeah you really can't
show the environment all like oh no so
that back look ago
that's a time shot that's a shot for a
certain time and the way the buzzer goes
that's like early 90s
is this [ __ ] snowfall man that's
crazy you put that together yeah real
quick i'm like uh that's all bus
environment behind us you need to be in
a time this is a 90 shot and that show
looks like it was shot in the early 80s
late 90s like it's supposed to be that's
what it's supposed to be
i don't know man i wasn't knows i've
been surrounded by all these [ __ ]
people filming it's been so tight
i love it so much man and our [ __ ]
our set's almost done the painter comes
on friday
he's about to kill he's the one that did
the hermes building correct yeah he's
done
yeah we'll shout him out we're going to
film it we're going to put together a
video he's excited to do that
but
yeah i'm really excited about it oh what
guys you showed me is unfucking yeah we
showed him this and he quoted us
i don't think we need
your
the quote you're thinking bro
it's pretty much just tracing yeah and
he goes all right
way less all right thank you cause
that's a good life lesson though because
every time we go to do something big
like when we first got the set built we
got an interesting
so you're gonna charge me 15k to make a
table [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
they should have once said hey how about
this back office
yeah soundproofing for you yeah okay for
sure that would have been nice they were
literally just like this is what you
want all right we'll do it twenty-five
thousand dollars but yeah everybody's
more than that yeah it's like 26
something yeah we chopped that down by
about 98
and then this set cost us [ __ ]
two two and a half racks to make
[Laughter]
oh you know what no
table might the set was expensive the
walls weren't yeah right the walls are
charging
but same idea with this one we got to a
really good place with that mm-hmm
and it's gonna be done fast me and
you've painted the both sides again yeah
oh yeah
yeah take a picture
let's do it like
it was it was it felt really good and
weird doing it again i know but this
time i'm looking at like it's real now
that's a thing this is where the [ __ ]
the guests are gonna sit that's where
their guests go and they get in the
green room because we have a green room
we don't use
it's so legit it's so legit it's got a
glass wall you can see straight through
we don't even use it and we picked this
hot warehouse to make a set mm-hmm
yeah we're high but it's nice because
it's like we get to upgrade now yeah now
it's an upgrade
it really is i'm excited we're about to
get traffic lighting and track so it
splashes of color behind us
you'll see it's gonna be a whole girl
yeah it's gonna be all right start
getting into real life i'm thinking
have you ever seen fern gully
oh yeah okay i'm thinking fern gully at
night when he starts like whoa
everything's alive that's what i want
the set to look like like
sick
it's gonna make a huge difference yeah
especially when you walk in and it's not
oh it's
106 in here
that's how bad it is in here yeah i
think it's disgusting in here yeah we
can film at normal hours we can film it
two in the afternoon get back it won't
be [ __ ] three in the morning already
was an hour or something away bro like
he goes home and it's late as [ __ ] we
don't get filled done filmed to one of
the eight one in the morning sometimes
yeah
and i'm getting those kids to school
shortly thereafter
all in one room because you're building
your house
they're all stuck in one room i'm so
excited to shoot my after video because
i put up the before one on instagram
this [ __ ] is gonna be [ __ ] epic we've
done so much you know what's funny
you're like me like
if it's for
something i'm doing client-wise i'm
crushing it for myself i'll just film
with my phone real quick yeah that's all
you did was yeah exactly
how much camera equipment you didn't
walk through your house right
you didn't do it before that's totally
like that that's me oh what's up
sick i'm gonna edit it [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah yeah
i don't know why if it's for somebody
else i'm on it i'll [ __ ] be on my
knee crop
zooming exactly
even for a friend but it's for me i'm
like no just just hold the camera right
here bro
bye
i'm done no videos done i don't know why
i've never put effort into my own things
for myself just for other stuff i feel
more natural putting less effort into it
like the videos on my youtube before i
started doing the podcast
i wasn't probably as comfortable just
talking on camera and as used to it but
i was wild a [ __ ] performer oh you
didn't perform live you said not so much
i mean it wasn't that i mean it would do
it like how you do your videos right set
it up and i'd take a couple [ __ ]
takes and eventually i would just get
one big long take of my whatever i'm
trying to talk about gotcha but now it's
like i i like i like doing lives now i
like talking to people on there i like
doing quick little drops and [ __ ] but
once i get back in my office this coming
week i'm gonna really deliberately try
to do like every other week a little
something informational to give people
not even that man you're gonna be able
to start coming out here at noon eleven
in the morning yeah hell yeah
i can't even imagine it's gonna be
[ __ ] we should start we should start
having people come here at one film till
three you can get home before traffic
we'll figure it out i think that'd be
great if we could start doing noon that
would be amazing
yeah people probably feel a little more
comfortable coming over here in the
daytime and [ __ ]
i think it's a little ghetto out here
[ __ ] just drunk over there so it's a
drunk [ __ ] it's just chilling
the street out here for some reason
and they're just pissing thomas is at
oddsworth constantly
man i feel like the [ __ ] the man and
chick you are dudes
and they don't think i'm magazine they
were talking mad [ __ ] about me in
spanish i'm like yo
i know some of those words they're like
i know some of those words is that how
he's reading george gilbert yeah all
right we're talking about all that good
burger yeah remember the movie the
feature film the sinbad is the teacher
and he's reading the [ __ ]
oh i know some of these words yeah
that's that's how i feel about these
fools like i know some of those that
means [ __ ] ass white boy
[ __ ] you i know what that means you
[ __ ] i was gonna fight one of these
little bastards
i i pretended like i knew spanish the
other day
[Laughter]
we had this one painter who was [ __ ]
up like
when we were in the hotel
[Laughter]
yeah
we were in the [ __ ] hotel for like
five days over this goddamn painter he's
telling us he's gonna be done on
saturday here we are [ __ ] thursday
so now thursday comes and he's talking
about sunday or some [ __ ]
and meanwhile he tried to get april to
pam
so i'm pissed
i'm like april's like no we can have our
contractor explain to him in spanish i'm
like [ __ ] that i need him to feel my
energy right now i'm going there i don't
i don't like
he's he's got us in a [ __ ] hotel like
and he's doing a [ __ ] job of paint so i
went in there we just painted in four
hours yeah i know i could have just
[ __ ] did it myself for what we were
paying this for yeah so yeah i go in
there and i start pressing this
[ __ ] right in the house and then
it's that thing where it's like i can't
tell if this fool's slow or if he just
really doesn't speak english at all
because
i'm dipping my toe into [ __ ] press on
this fool and he's not connecting what
i'm even talking about he's just like
so then i get david our contractor come
on he speaks spanish so
i'm now i'm just kind of ranting and
david's translating for me and then i
had already kind of like preemptively
talked to him about this and
knew what i was saying i don't know [ __ ]
about construction or paint or like or
spanish or spanish none of this [ __ ]
and we were like yeah we already had the
wall textured so i'm not understanding
why you're charging us 400 to texture
this wall
and then
translate translate translate and then
i'm like
uh it doesn't or
it doesn't cost 400
to texture the wall
he translates it now to the dude and i'm
like
he said something back something back
and i'm like yeah it doesn't cost that
much does it i heard like cinquenta i
heard i heard a number and then the dude
did the movement literally doing this
yeah [ __ ] behind the guy yeah exactly
but there was a moment where
i chimed in where i it seemed like i was
like you knew what he said it doesn't
cost that though doesn't matter you
pretended to know uh yeah
i heard it i heard a number and i'm like
we're talking about the texture
wasn't 400 was it i got you it was good
you went oh [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying
oh [ __ ] and then yeah i fired them i i
was like
canceling this [ __ ] it's [ __ ] over
i [ __ ] fired the dude on the spot
good yeah
i'm i love firing people now
i'm done i'm just done paying people and
going oh you [ __ ] it off
yeah you [ __ ] i felt bad because the
dude's telling me like
i always feel bad every time i'm like
bro i'm a freelancer you don't gotta
explain this [ __ ] to me i understand
you're coming up here [ __ ] this [ __ ]
up but now you got my family in a hotel
like
i can't let you [ __ ] us off forever and
you're paying the hotel and you're
paying it yeah exactly you're costing me
extra money now and
he was on another job like i found he
went on i'm like
no it's not my fault you're at a [ __ ]
separate gig now you're rushing to get
here at night time because this is one
of those i'll be done saturday or sunday
but now it's monday and i have a day job
or whatever so i
bro i didn't sign up for any of that
[ __ ] nor do i give a [ __ ] paint the
[ __ ] house
or don't outside or inside inside this
was the upstairs that's it just the
upstairs rollers or a spray
i don't know what the [ __ ] he was in
there not with spray he was doing a [ __ ]
ass job he didn't sand he didn't prime
he was we're peeling the paint off the
door frame sounds like my shirts
[Laughter]
yeah oh
you can't live with that and i can't
live with this yeah we both had to check
[ __ ] no it's funny when you
check that dude though because it's i
thought you were going live you're like
hey guys what's up so you start when i
send the video to the manufacturers like
hey guys what's up so yeah because
that's how i feel so and as i was
talking my
no
you can hear me and then i went and as i
started saying the things out loud to go
yeah i just got more man like oh so i
just opened this and it [ __ ] peeled
and i went it peeled it [ __ ] p and
then i started getting more mad like it
[ __ ] people so i do want to yell at
my kids yeah i try to start off real
adult
then i get a couple sentences in and
then now
circling around them with my fist
quenching [ __ ]
even three-year-old eight-year-old yeah
no not the three-year-old but she's a 14
year old too yeah no the
three-year-old's good she's straight
she's fine
yeah
but
i know what you mean i am like that with
her though too i'm [ __ ]
you start off trying to explain nicely
like she's [ __ ] funny you're not
gonna have that forever yeah i know
she's one of the funniest kids i've ever
[ __ ] come in contact with she has a
personality of like a 10 year old but
she's in the littlest body ever yeah i
save everything you send to me because
it's always [ __ ] hilarious
her staring down cam the other day was
the funniest [ __ ] ever i i know she
saves that always in her underwear i can
never put funny clips out of her because
she never has clothes yeah yeah she's oh
she never wants to wear anything right
as soon as we get in the house
underwear always
so that i can get all these funny clips
and i'm not gonna put her on [ __ ]
instagram in her [ __ ] underwear yeah
but yeah she's a goddamn character
you're her best friend legitimately
funny as hell it's really cool because i
don't have any family on my side so
every time thomas calls hi hi i already
i'm ready for it sometimes i beat her
every single time yeah in the back seat
no she's not getting paid attention she
comes running in the room yep there's
been hella tired she's right now i'm
talking to rosie and [ __ ] yeah
oh your nails
yeah like yo you got to say [ __ ]
you're just doing this
but she was in she's in [ __ ] make
believe land with cam she's got these
fake boarding passes oh yeah the video
and she's going with her little barbie
boarding passes yeah but does this have
to be does this have covid that's what
she's asking she's pretending they're
[ __ ] because they just went on a
flight that's probably what they asked
yeah so she's like yeah and cam's like
he did something in her fantasy world
that she didn't like and she's like bro
how am i how do i remember the story
better oh you sure
no she says you're gonna have to do your
boarding pass because i don't want to
yeah yeah
you don't want to
her fist dropped her
eyebrows went up like to her hips
it went from it's okay i just need you
to do your boarding pass to [ __ ] she
looks psychotic that's exactly what she
said i don't want to do it and she had a
pretzel in her hand
yeah she could see just the rage and her
little hands and then she went it's okay
like it was real yeah she had no clothes
on
her she's standing by a bed camp's
laying she's eating pretzels we're
trapped out of there meanwhile the bed's
on the floor we're eating [ __ ]
pretzels pretzels on the [ __ ] floor
eating dry ramen these foods are living
like [ __ ] they're broke
nice house is stuck in one room
it's ironic it's made yeah it's your
last taste of [ __ ] living
man it's like camping inside for it's
like camping inside
you mean having a house
yeah it's [ __ ] pretty campish though
i i always like referring to homeless
people these will sleep outside yeah he
just sleeps outside uh-huh
it's funnier that way it's like makes it
not as bad like oh he loves to sleep
outside all the time he drinks too much
and he'll sleep outside for years oh
[ __ ] you mean he's almost yes bro he's a
homeless drunk sleeping outside for a
long time i threatened my kids with that
too oh it's fine you'll just have to
live outside i tell my little brother
that too like you have to live outside
now well you hear me say things all the
time to people well you have to sleep on
the porch
i love meeting my foamy's kids because
it's either it's a hit or miss 99 of the
time they're like i [ __ ] with this guy
he says some wild [ __ ] to me
i love [ __ ] with people's kids
because it's always like
i love [ __ ] people's kids until they
realize my my magic tricks are just
i
sleight of hand and [ __ ] like when i
pretend to float on one foot from the
side
bro my little brother is nine johnny he
still thinks that's true every what you
do is you put one foot back your front
foot they stand from the side and you
lift up your front foot it looks like
you lift off the ground like this but
what you do is you lift your right foot
under the side of your shoe so by that
time you can't see the foot and it looks
like you're above the ground i do this
i always do that and like pretend to
fall
and my little brother rocco when he was
a kid i told him
they always teach you in fifth grade but
only if you have really good grades
right when you graduate fifth grade they
show you how to do the flying thing
flying shoes my uh supras he said you
got your flying shoes today yep i do
well brother my other little brother my
sister
justin's daughter stella still believes
that known for three years and she's
like eight she still thinks i can fly
she still thinks i can [ __ ] fly just
watch whenever i'm gonna get her all
right what the [ __ ]
[Music]
if your kid still believes that i'm
going to slap the [ __ ] out of them
at 18. that's a good point gonna suck
them right in the chest are you [ __ ]
yeah yeah i was gonna fly yeah i fool
everybody's kids at that i love doing it
and they never go don't [ __ ] with my kid
they go thank you uh-huh like yep
and i do the smoke trick
like at sixth grade that freaked out me
and all the [ __ ] fans when you did
that yeah
i know i know but when you do it to kids
ago
uh my little sister
elizabeth said that i swallowed a piece
of firewood when i was a kid and that's
why i can do it
she believed that she was like [ __ ]
oh because you have like a piece of
firewood in your stomach i'm like yep
in sixth grade when i got really good
grades they showed me
i used to say that all the time because
by the time you hit sixth grade if you
don't believe you believe me then you're
never graduating
so that's pretty much the cut off you
know if you still believe that [ __ ] by
then i'm gonna [ __ ] hit you uh-huh
you're gonna live outside
you're definitely gonna live outside
well when i was when i was 16 i picked
up my girlfriend
and her friend and my dad's
forest hunter green station wagon bomb
we're talking nice you've never watched
70's show your dad sounds like redform
yeah it could be you say
yeah
this is i mean this was an old ass
station wagon this is the one that the
doors would freeze open i'd have to
drive around oh
[ __ ] doors closed
this was an old this was not a nice car
okay so i'm just setting the scene here
this is the wagon you know
and she's in the back seat and i'm like
she's like can you roll down the windows
and i'm like they're voice activated
just go ahead stop i'm like just saying
what just you know tell them to go down
they'll go down she's like windowed down
and i had it on the front seat
here that's just like oh my [ __ ] god
try it again window window up
and i get i don't [ __ ] i mean it wasn't
space-age technology to have the [ __ ]
auto windows on the driver's seat but it
blew her [ __ ] mind it's just high but
she was like 15 16. that's okay i could
see people getting fooled by that i can
see that happening like whoa
oh you're a [ __ ] you have a button over
there i can see that happening rocco my
little brother thought i had a nos
button in my monte carlo for
six years and i told him i had a button
i can press and it dries by itself
because he's always in the back seat he
can't see my left knee and i would just
drive on my left knee but look
all right tell him where to go left i
just hit it and then all to do is my
move my right leg the old steering was a
rubber grippy so i would just push it
and i would turn like that without him
looking
like rocco you drive pretty probably
pretty good i would i did that till he
was like 10 years old but the nos button
like all right ready and i'd reach under
my seat there's nothing there and all i
did was just gun it hit the gas
and i let him press it one time
i love [ __ ] with kids yeah they
always get hyped though that's the best
parts like yo you
wish i had a me when i was a kid
everybody seriously dick there was an
[ __ ] nobody did cool [ __ ]
they just [ __ ] with me yeah i mean you
live half your life in [ __ ]
fantasyland it's cool you can
my kids want nothing more than me to
[ __ ] just
go off into some crazy [ __ ] pretend
sketch bit with them all the time i mean
as you see
so they do they'll
live off in fantasy world for hours at a
time
it's all right it's the clipboard oh it
scared me i thought it was going outside
these headphones yeah
yeah here we go well how long we in
hour 20. no we're not
has it really yeah
we only got [ __ ] three notes here's
three notes four notes and one says
intro
four notes one says inch
i really thought it was an hour and a
half today man i gotta get up early and
do a wild ass wee challenge video so
looking forward to that yeah here we go
oh yeah guys
stop how did we get in okay here we go i
don't know what we're talking about
i'm gonna bring something up we'll talk
about it slightly probably never bring
it up again until we're like yeah we won
the court case so here we go guys marty
and i remember like episode three we
talked about holy [ __ ]
it happened we got signed to a brand
agency
they're gonna help us with our ad reads
they have not gotten us one ad just
letting you know marty and i have done
everything our own ads until a couple
weeks ago and we got branded on board
and brought from syria
that's what i'm talking about i'm saying
they were supposed to get us ad reads
and they got us nothing besides what i'm
about to talk about remember stereo
we're doing that app
uh it was [ __ ] fun i loved it one of
the guys died so they stopped it right
and we we even talked about the podcast
we're not gonna just like no
keep going with the contract like no bro
it's serious let's chill but yeah they
were our first like sponsors they were
our first anything first anything even
though we were getting deals by
ourselves though next week anyway they
never got us one other deal we told them
no we companies and all they did was
bring us weed companies
bro i'll do that by myself and get more
money than you're gonna get
[ __ ] wrong with you anyway
who i'm talking about is notorious
notorious llc notorious whatever the
[ __ ] you want to call them the pieces of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
so what happened guys is we have never
been paid
we have still not gotten paid
for our entire [ __ ] first campaign
that we talked we were talking about
like how excited we were it's like holy
[ __ ] we're actually gonna make money
they haven't even paid us yet they're
supposed to pay us net 60. it's been six
[ __ ] months
still haven't paid us i'm only getting
into this because
uh we not talked about it and i'm not
gonna let it go and we love stereo i
like stereo we were streaming live it
was cool i love it we just had to we had
to stop because all this [ __ ] that
happened and the contract got [ __ ] and
they got stereo got [ __ ] too
so
what's this guy's name
peter vince peter vincent jarvis
no no no jarvis
the guy that owns notorious
jarvis uh
no i know that that's somebody i [ __ ]
know probably peter vincent there he
goes right there there it is peter vince
this guy owns notorious llc i usually
will never say this but i'm putting my
[ __ ] blast
that is not him did he gain a shitload
of weight that's him
yeah i mean holy [ __ ] that's what he
that's he's
baiting people that holds 350 pounds
heavier than that right now yo he's
pulling girls with that picture
that's [ __ ] up don't put that picture
up he looks cool in this picture don't
put that looks like put the shitty
version of him up seth rogen in that
goddamn picture he looks cool right
there like no he's probably pulling
girls with that
[ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] there he is is that him
[ __ ] i don't [ __ ] mind anyway we
get on the call with this guy all this
stuff because they owe us 25 [ __ ]
thousand dollars they actually owed a 75
but we stopped the contract
it's a lot of money to us man 25 dollars
a [ __ ] shitload of money especially
when we're doing all this ourselves
podcast completely in the rest yeah
still and still kind of in the red
but we're doing our thing
guys
this guy straight lied to us on the
[ __ ] phone for three weeks straight
we talked a stereo like yeah we gave him
700 000 advance and they didn't do any
of the stuff and now they're not
answering
and we're talking this guy's like yeah
we never got payment so you know i'll
pay you when i can while we're going
through this blah blah blah and by the
way he was talking he got off the phone
i called martin to go he's lying
and you even said oh he's [ __ ] lying
we said at the same time this guy's a
[ __ ] liar i can tell by the way he
was talking that he's a piece of [ __ ]
i was a drug dealer i know when your
[ __ ] ass can pay me for the
front and you got the money and you say
you don't got the money
i know when people are lying yeah but
even his story didn't add up he's like i
never see the vibe just the vibe
he was saying oh you're talking too much
already i didn't get a chance to say
anything that means you have you're
trying to cover something it was word
vomit word vomit word vomit but then we
just make a couple little points
oh you're a liar
okay cool anyway
turns out
this guy's being sued and remember that
giant house we filmed at when marty
actually killed the butterfly
[ __ ] guy was squatting
he was squatting in that place he wasn't
even paying the [ __ ] rent guys we got
hustled hard
so shout out to notorious llc for being
because we addressed [ __ ] we addressed
it on instagram one of the [ __ ]
neighbors reached out one of the
neighbors reached out to me because he's
a filing a class action lawsuit and has
hundreds of petitions against this guy
because he beat the [ __ ] out of one of
the [ __ ] old gardeners that's one i
stopped once i realized that i'm like oh
this guy's a piece [ __ ] i'm done i'm
just gonna assume i'm done not waiting
on him i'm like yo he's beating up an
old ass man yeah there's like a video of
him get the [ __ ] off my property that's
really [ __ ] it's just nasty with like
four other dude and this guy's huge
he's like six [ __ ] seven he was a
monster remember we met him i don't
remember thinking that about him but no
he was [ __ ] me oh you're like six
three but he was [ __ ] big i remember
just thinking about everything like i'm
like this goofy looking [ __ ] is
in charge of this [ __ ] i even thought
that like
i feel like he's on love on the spectrum
that's how i felt about him like yo are
you competent to do this [ __ ] apparently
not and then he gave us a run around get
on the phone with us but you know riley
reed porn star [ __ ] gets paid
i mean honor means like she's a [ __ ]
sorry i'm i'm just talking
the porn star woman the girl i don't
mean she's she's probably super nice i
mean nothing bad about her but and the
other girl lana lana something on the
road
she got her [ __ ] money
but the kid's stiffing us he's paying
his [ __ ] rent at his own house with
our [ __ ] monies what's going on
and like me and marty said
oh when we talked about it months ago
like we don't want to show up in
anyone's house but i'll [ __ ] show up
at your house that house is seized by
l.a county now we can't even show up at
the guy's house because i'm not going to
say that
hypothetically i would have showed up
and beat the [ __ ] out of this man
hypothetically
i'm not going to do that i'm a nice
person
i'm not going to do that i'm not saying
it i'm not saying it as a threat
in another universe
and or if i was on the internet i would
just showed up at his house and broke
everything he [ __ ] ever owned with
[ __ ] 12 people
i'm like all right i feel like i was 25
racks and i'm taking your car and i'm
gonna sell it to rick ross's old [ __ ]
chop shop i don't know i don't know but
i know i'm like you're not gonna just
take the [ __ ] money you owe us like
it just snapped in my hand like
i never trusted them
that's why i went they gave us and this
is like really great business stuff
because they gave us a contract i took
that [ __ ] and completely rewrote their
contract and gave it back to him it's
like nah [ __ ] none of this is working
crazy this is what we'll do this is what
we'll do and it puts you in a completely
non-exclusive place with us whereas if
you bring us any money cool if not
cool but
originally they were trying to goddamn
own the show basically they wanted part
of the show they wanted to put their
logo on the [ __ ] wall they want to
put their logo on the thumbnail and say
brought to you by notorious llc you
could suck my [ __ ] dick
so
anyway they thought they were playing
these two high kids in all actuality
it's like yo i will [ __ ] you up
financially
yeah i mean not and physically it's like
we're dealing with a goddamn alleged
full-blown con man so yeah he's a con
artist but anyway peter vince [ __ ]
we talked about on instagram and dude i
feel bad but there was like 4 000
comments on these guys pages going hard
on them and i never asked for that but i
appreciate you guys having our [ __ ]
backs like that we're just trying to
keep you posted on what the [ __ ] we just
wanted yeah we just want to let you guys
know what was happening i'm not going to
bring on a sponsor like stereo and be
all on it and actually like it letting
you know we like it and then we'll be
skipping
that and we told that's we expressed
that to these fools off the top we
talked to stereo directly they go
he said they weren't paid so we gave him
700 000 [ __ ] dollars
remember he's like and now it's been
what do you say uh
on their end it's been something on
their end what's it called when people
don't respond
yeah i mean yeah
they said like a saying like
dead air yeah radio silence yeah
complete radio silence from them like
damn she just said radio silence that's
what she said that's when i knew like
oh so anyway we call him and he gives us
a whole different story like this
bastard yeah that was one of those we
already know the answer is all that yeah
we know the answers yep it's like we
knew we it's like we watched him rob
somebody from the window and it went out
it was just but it was creepy because he
kept getting on the phone that's what
was he kept on the phone because he
thought we were really nice yeah and we
are we're really nice super [ __ ] nice
even on the phone we didn't go off on
them and the second we went well what if
we just do this can you just make
payments well you know if you want to
get on the lawsuit with me and pay a
lawyer and do with all these go ahead go
oh he's a liar
gotcha you're a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] so
shout out to peter for being a [ __ ]
[ __ ] um
we usually never talk about this stuff
but we have to [ __ ] talk about it we
were so hyped
the tour
[ __ ] you guys anyway they got seat their
house got seized then they're over here
[ __ ] doing mgk and travis barker
[ __ ] music video at the house but
they can't pay us our [ __ ] money
that's what pisses me off the most that
sure really bothered me for a while
really pisses me off and i kind of
forgot about it till this morning i
forgot about it after i realized the
severity of the whole scenario and was
way bigger than us like
i stopped taking it so personally we're
not the only people that got [ __ ] yeah
like 30 other podcasts didn't get paid
or maybe they didn't maybe they did who
the [ __ ] knows who knows maybe they did
after i saw that video with him in the
garden the garden was like this is
different i might have been thinking
about the [ __ ] podcast anymore like
just gonna leave it alone yeah like you
know what if i ever get our money
it's cool we get everybody
we did so well with stereo that you know
it was it was all right
yeah you don't [ __ ] the money guys it's
not it's just like yo i would love to
have that money right now
of course super yeah i mean uh yeah you
got people starting a [ __ ] business
here we got warehouse we got houses like
that's that's not quite a deal but
also at the same time you know
we've gotten a lot of good things in our
favor that's why we haven't really been
complaining yeah i mean until now i'm
obviously just bitching but
we you know we had this chance to check
in with the fans on the solo episode and
[ __ ] so we got to keep people posting on
what we got going on because we really
mean it when we say with these ad
partners like
we're not taking on [ __ ] phony cheesy
ads just to take them on like most
possibilities
that early on in season one when they we
had nothing
we were just hoping to get sponsors like
really you know
we're
just yeah they just basically walked us
for it and we went the extra mile with
that [ __ ] and did multiple live streams
so much just because we're like wow this
brand agency really wants to help us
great and they let us write our own
contract
and we're making money from them and i
was just shocked that we're gonna get
paid oh my god
we never get paid for [ __ ] so we're like
oh it's real and then there's four or
five months later six months later like
you know this guy's a piece of [ __ ] yeah
it's okay it's okay we'll eventually
when we get really paid i'll go to him
i'll go soon and take his [ __ ] volvo
or whatever he's got [ __ ] [ __ ]
i hope he's got a new volvo so i could
take that [ __ ] i doubt it people like
that man i hope he's got a brand new
something so i can go hey seizing it
[ __ ] you i highly doubt this fool
doesn't have anything you probably owe
so many people [ __ ] he's just kind of
going house to house without who the
[ __ ] knows but we both got off the phone
went i'm glad we could tell [ __ ]
yeah we both caught wit guy's a [ __ ]
liar yeah of course seconds into the i
called you i'm just glad that you saw it
too yeah
it was one of the questions being able
to tell a lie and never get caught or
being able to hear every lie you hear
mm-hmm and you said we already have that
mm-hmm i'd rather be able to line up a
cough because i can already tell the
lies are off the bat
um
and now that we're experienced too we
were completely interested we were brand
new they they really did get us it's a
[ __ ] 45 million dollar house
go up there they're filming a music
video in there
and they're like yeah sign blah blah
blah i'm like yeah all right we're cool
not exclusive because we're not dumb
good thing we didn't
and um
just like damn we did all that work and
you guys didn't pay us any of our
[ __ ] money not a dollar
it's all good we have many more cool
things coming to us so it's fine but one
day guys we'll reach back on this when
we go hey we want our money
yeah hell yeah so note that that's it
so for everyone out there if you start a
new business even us we started a new
business got [ __ ] immediately we
didn't talk about it it's been
six months we still didn't talk about it
because
we're not just to sit here and complain
and use our platform to go hey
hey [ __ ] you we've we're really [ __ ]
mad behind the scenes oh we're really
going at it
[ __ ] pissed yeah talking about the
clothes today pissed me off because i
wanted and usually i would just not talk
about it and just
not talk about it but i want to let you
guys know like yo i'm i'm doing all this
[ __ ] all this [ __ ] and i still get stuff
still happy yes real person living out
real life it still happens guys so if
you're out there with a clothing company
or something and [ __ ] [ __ ] up
don't look at it like [ __ ] i can't do
anything right and get [ __ ]
it happens man it happens
and sometimes it's the shittiest timing
like today it's two days brand new site
i already talked about it looking at
that ride
i went through so much trouble for that
rack
i know so much i went through three
different things
[ __ ] getting here from 300 miles away
yeah then having a pressure washer and
pick up all these p and my back's been
[ __ ] up so picking them up i'm like ah
i know every piece
is really [ __ ] up yeah every piece
i've been like
and i had to do it three times get it in
get it out get it in and then put it
together
and every box three times to get it here
move it go through it put it back move
it over there to get the racks then put
it on the racks
[Laughter]
no you can't even drop these goddamn
clothes
it's okay
it's okay
my life is seinfeld man my life is
[ __ ] straight seinfeld i love it
that's why i have so many story times
that was a story time
i got expanded on that [ __ ] for [ __ ]
15 minutes talking about how i met these
guys and all the [ __ ] and all the dope
[ __ ] i hope they come back i hope they
come back and i just say hey remember
that first time i can't believe you guys
[ __ ] up that bad on the first run yeah
this is run number 30 now like that's
what i want to say because they're so
dope
the bags are so good
everything they've made me so far is
perfect
for the thing that cost me almost the
most money like come on man [ __ ]
i keep forgetting i got so much money in
these bags right here
that rack is worth a lot of [ __ ]
racks
but so it's crazy dude i never thought
like from
spending 400 bucks on some shirts and
[ __ ] like uh-huh
racks on racks oh it's so weird
putting like a house payment into a
project yeah
is so cool like it's very it's flipping
at a high [ __ ] level yeah it really
is like very odd but now i'm looking at
this and going
those big companies got four warehouses
this big and this is about
like wow you guys are crushing it
also you got employees but one day we'll
get there it's just very cool to see it
i like seeing this and going i always
tell rosie to look back and go we're
going to look back and go remember our
little first warehouse yeah i always say
that
we're gonna look back that's manifesting
that's how you're supposed to yeah
because i'm gonna [ __ ] have that
expanded block warehouse and half of
it's gonna be the weed brand and half
it's gonna be push trees i already see
it it's gonna happen i'm gonna have like
45 40 employees i can see it already
it's making me think i'm the my family's
shirt packed me back in buffalo like
same exact [ __ ] that's why i'm like [ __ ]
they did it if anybody can do it [ __ ]
you can do it
let's work hard yeah
it's if you have 10 people one of them's
gonna be a good worker
and he's gotta find that one
and i haven't found them yet
i mean besides obviously us then that's
it
everyone else is [ __ ] with me i go
through new manufactures that's
discouraging
if you're so deep into this clothing
[ __ ] we're trying to get the podcast
apparel line right it's like god damn
first merch guys straight literally took
dicks and just ate them he sucked
he just [ __ ] it off
like yo we need to hunt oh get to it
yeah i didn't feel real great about it
i'm not i'm good i just we just can't
wait around for people not to work
me and you are working we need
enthusiasm many people are working
that's why brandon's [ __ ] working
[ __ ] brandon he's basically what the
tour is supposed to be yeah exactly but
he's a 19 year old kid who's [ __ ]
cool as [ __ ] too so it makes it even
better yeah he's he's hella tight so
that's our guy but
other than that dude like [ __ ] man it's
hard to find people that are willing to
i try to tell people when i'm
interviewing i'm like i don't want to
sound douchey but i've just worked with
so many people me and thomas are the
best coolest people you can work for in
this business oh when it comes to being
like no brothers do your job that's all
i ask we're going to give you everything
you need we're going to be everything
i'll never yell at you
never give me a
i'll give you i'll help you in any way i
can never treat you less than or never
trying to block you out of something you
want to hit this yeah
do you want it after you're done
[ __ ]
like man bro like you could be the
easiest people to work for for because
it's not like that coming up man it
really wasn't
really it was not like that yeah dude
like i know people hit us up with like
this i'll move out there to work like i
don't need it yet yeah are you a booking
agent that's what i need yeah these
opportunities are coming kind of
incrementally yeah can you do graphics
as good as marty and you need a job
maybe in like a week or two or a couple
months jurassic graphics be hiring again
that's what we need we need another
marty so while we're here the other
marty is doing all the clips for the
episode we just [ __ ] finished
yeah have the episode you know what i
mean like wow
do we do a lot of work for no time every
hour of the day is boom boom boom for me
and on top you have three [ __ ] kids
but season two
season two the fans are gonna see the
difference my whole life is about to
really kick it in i haven't even i feel
like i'm just getting started i really
feel like mike just got wrecked
childhood yeah childhood just ended
yeah
i've gotten everything i wanted in life
so now i gotta really just go after it
as just like a thank you
just give it everything i have yeah dude
that's uh i'm not at that stage yet i'm
at the
oh yeah i guess it's the exact same
stage no
i just want a billion [ __ ] dollars
and then go i need 10
not because i want to be rich just
because i can go
all right everyone's got a house bro
we're good oh you need to work start a
business i own 15 of your liquor store
i'll open it pay me back done
i own 50 of your walmart pay me back
done
and everyone in my family can make 85
[ __ ] percent of what they never would
have made i just get 15 back like i'll
front you all the money for every
[ __ ] thing until it's paid back be
done now it's your business
how cool that's how you make change yeah
that's how you
because you put one of your [ __ ]
family members to open a store and what
happens when they become what you were
and helping the next person and the next
person your family the next person their
friend and that one business employs
five [ __ ] people and those kids are
in high school now he's got a car and
he's not stripping off money and it's
just
we say it all the time middle eastern
people got the [ __ ] tech down they
come here they open one store they open
another store what they're cutting down
they own that oh you help me with this
okay bringing more people in from our
family from another country you're gonna
help me with the store then you're gonna
own your own store then you're gonna and
that's the way it's supposed to be
uh one of my good friends dude that
referred us the painter i mean he's
balling right now off that model that
his parents set up for him billy stood
too yeah he's nominees he's now he's
they got the right idea i'm around the
world doing whatever he wants because i
love it i love the culture businesses
back in buffalo running and
that's all it takes man complex liquor
cigarettes
liquor store stuff will never go out of
[ __ ] business
are you ready
even bums contribute to [ __ ] stores
bombs are your best customer at the
liquor i know it's like oh your feet
you know what happens then don't make
this liquor store and let the other guy
[ __ ] do it
it's just liquor [ __ ] people
drink it
no sell it it's legal what the [ __ ]
wrong with you people i like liquor
but some people eat too much mcdonald's
too there it is
i'm just saying like
liquor small [ __ ] cigarettes
liquor store style stuff will never go
out have you ever seen a liquor store
out of business [ __ ] never it might
have burned down
yeah that's the only way liquor goes out
of business that's [ __ ] it
or the person dies their kid takes over
they're a tweaker and they've run it
into the ground i've seen that happen
other than that dude no liquor store's
ever gone out of [ __ ] business m a
market is still there and merced
circle g is still [ __ ] there if you
know where i'm at
i'm not wrong california liquor is never
going anywhere
all right
anyway start that business
marty's on the just grew up thing
big time it's you know it's crazy
i did all my math i can finally go start
trying to look for a house um
i haven't
i don't have the whole down payment but
i know you could do first
i'm not trying to do like a big ass loan
or anything i feel
i feel like like next year we're going
to be just buying our houses i don't i
don't know why i feel it mm-hmm like
we're putting too much we're putting in
so much every something's gonna it's
gonna what we're doing what we're doing
we're taking the steps and going
remember when you'll remember we used to
[ __ ] book our own people man
that [ __ ] took days
and now we're working on the grocery i
totally want to open the grocery store
i'm like now i'm on the grocery store in
this day tuesdays are grocery store days
because i don't have to do all the
editing anymore i have some meals to
edit now and you're like no i have
drastic graphics going on i don't even
edit anymore man i have four [ __ ]
employees sitting there working all day
great
perfect
that's the stage i feel like i'm at
right now i'm almost like
because as a house 20 percent
just 10
you have to put 10 yeah but you don't
have to put 20.
it depends what kind of deal you got
going on i'm no expert in that [ __ ] but
i know what standard is 10.
never mind maybe i want to get the house
a little faster than i thought oh man
that's a lot of money i mean but it
helped it helped my man let me start
[ __ ] getting you excited do you know
any like realtors or anything
i might you might
oh
you have kids without
a couple you don't know
i don't know because she knows that [ __ ]
listen it goes so deep like the dude i'm
editing your [ __ ] video yesterday
she's got the salesman coming over with
the windows now she's already sold on
the windows she's already looked at the
[ __ ] windows i'm up editing the video
my [ __ ] eyes are bothering me all up
in the house i'm [ __ ] squinting up
there
this is yesterday
i'm all [ __ ] same [ __ ] though this
dude is like i'd really like to shoot
your husband he like requests to show me
these [ __ ] windows
and i'm like
i come down
they pull me away from the computer i
i'm up against that i know i got to like
leave
and [ __ ] out to uh you know go get the
kids and [ __ ] like
my body language is like what what bro
she's handling this she's gonna buy it
the dude stinks like [ __ ] cologne
he's going through his whole sales pitch
my [ __ ] eyes are now we're outside i
can barely see what the [ __ ] is going on
and i was just like all right i just i
just walked away like she's she's
handling this like cool
sales pitch god damn it
you know you're like [ __ ] forcing
this ear beating of your sales pitch on
me bro we're going to [ __ ] buy these
winners you say we want them
we're getting the whole house get the
[ __ ] windows but he had to was he
like old school i thought he had to talk
to a guy
i maybe that might have maybe that might
have been it we both talk weirdos stop
bro she's
she knows all this stuff i don't know
[ __ ] about windows i didn't even you're
weird he was like you see how your
windows that you got got a green tint to
them i'm like
you know what they do got a [ __ ]
green dot i don't even [ __ ] notice
that
but yeah
watch quick games bro i'm talking about
talking about glass pieces of glass
sorry i watched that episode last night
go watch sweet games
yeah [ __ ] that but you get into [ __ ]
buying a house you do not expect
all i mean i've blinded about this every
stage on the podcast from not being able
to find one to getting in but it's okay
because this is a three occurring theme
of season one season one marty was
buying his house yeah that's true
that's true it's
it's we ended it by the time we end this
season yeah guys season's coming to an
end sorry i'm just saying that now
we probably only have a couple more
episodes in the season all right
wow cool
we got through a whole season so it'll
probably be about maybe you know we're
at 35. next season will probably look
more like 50
and then we'll switch it up again wow
man yeah
but all right zooming out at the life of
the podcast zooming out we're still
brand new for sure we'll be we'll be
what we are around like i said season
three season three and a half i think
four where is this going to be well
season four of any major comedy is the
best season
go watch season four the office co watch
season four of oh it's sunny love you
guys go watch season four always sunny
season four seinfeld oh [ __ ] gems
yeah every time rosie what's what do you
want you watch season four episode four
i say it all the time season four
episode four is always good on whatever
[ __ ] show you're watching if it's
comedy at least
always
if it's not a show that has to be in
plot
next week we're on a river that [ __ ]
season 4 episode 4 is going
all right it's like people say just put
c on the scantron just go see his
[ __ ] four man
um
see our season four is gonna be great
i can't wait
[ __ ] i can't [ __ ] scares me to look
that far in the future at this point
don't don't be scared season five
season five will be on tv
i don't know i'm just saying i'm talking
my ass at this point
we'll see what's going on at that point
doing the same thing oh my god jimmy
kimmel bro whenever you get bored just
[ __ ] come knock
all right
just come [ __ ] i'll just take over
your job as long as they let me smoke
johnny carson used to be able to sit
there with a cigarette so ronnie
dangerfield
you know and then he just smoked and
drank why can't i just you know smoke a
drink too
the [ __ ]
but you know like on late night
yo johnny carson was good
i watched so many clips
you [ __ ] running dangerfield
i don't [ __ ] with them i mean i'm aware
who he is he gets no respect i know all
that [ __ ] oh okay okay his stand-up's
really good
he's a funny [ __ ] oh gee [ __ ]
he's just funny he's just that guy he
got famous at 55.
he didn't get no movies or nothing he
was famous at 50 [ __ ] five years old
i i saw that that came up when he
was still alive when i was a kid
and it popped up on extra extra that
show remember yeah it'd pop up i used to
watch it but come on oh sick man action
[ __ ] i was always in the movies
and talked about ryan dangerfield happy
something something birthday at the end
of the show two seven some did you know
a little fact that he did not and they
talked about how 55 he super got he
finally got famous
he had been doing it for so long and he
finally popped off at 55 or 45 i can't
remember but either way
for all these people out there thinking
it's not going to happen keep [ __ ]
pushing at it look at it now [ __ ]
dude and suicide squad iris ibrahim what
the motherfucker's been in hella [ __ ]
for 30 years
he was in the episode of absolutely
fabulous i don't know if you watched
that show it's one of my favorite
[ __ ] shows
randomly absolutely fabulous is a show
about two chicks in england that's
really funny
what's the [ __ ] you're really good at
not giving out spoilers i don't well one
is a super bad alcoholic and she's great
she doesn't hasn't eaten anything since
1973 patsy stone
she just does coke and drinks and smokes
and her
friend eddie
eddie is a
like a fashion
head mogul fashion she's well known
but she's like overweight so she's never
like in the circle of being high fashion
people even though she runs one of the
biggest [ __ ] spot magazines i think
okay
it's just really funny my mom put me on
when i was a kid
it's really good it [ __ ] ends with
david bowie like it's just all it just
reminds me of being a kid
a lot of the episodes end with [ __ ]
little david bowie riff i just [ __ ] with
it don't know why i brought that up
anyway
i have no idea why i brought this this
is a diva
oh
jesus
okay
we got off topic notorious [ __ ] done
wrap that up
ready guys
i don't think i've ever told the story
marty says he's never heard this
this isn't season one story time
it's a long time before i ever met you
um
you ready
my notes just say crazy asian gangster
party
you ever seen that show that came out
called crazy rich asians this is my
version yeah
all right interpreted by ella yeah it's
called crazy asian gangster party if you
watch season one story time and a lot of
people during the college episode kept
saying yo i've heard that story before
you [ __ ] up guys 90 of the stories i
talk about on this show are from a story
time somewhere
so if you heard before it's probably
because you've been watching for a long
time but the reason i talk about it is i
can go way more in depth because there's
no editing there's no hey you got that
black box hey
like that
[ __ ]
smell proof
not stab proof i did stab through it
what you guys saw on the video it went
through one
in the back
well i mean it didn't go all the way
through but it went into the box yeah
that cop was wrong behind a buck knife
[ __ ] rambo knife
um
oh man there was something i was gonna
talk about i can't remember anymore i
had it like right here now it's gone
[ __ ]
anyway crazy asian games party here we
go um
i've never talked i've never talked
about
sure ecstasy parties and [ __ ] yeah we
haven't we haven't talked about ecstasy
on the show yet we've had one one asian
gangster mentioned
which one was that when we talked about
that i didn't realize there was asian
gangsters
and this is not you have not heard the
story
guys i promise from now on i'll never
ask have i told this before my goal for
this week is to go through every single
[ __ ] podcast skim it write down every
story i've talked about so i never have
to ask that again
because i feel like it's a little
unprofessional of me to ask did i do
this yet
sorry like i just talk a lot all right i
talk a lot i have three different shows
we do this we do the [ __ ] story time
we do eventually [ __ ] i go on lives
i don't know what i talked about on
where okay like lil wayne i have to
google my lyrics to make sure i didn't
say it already
that's what i have to do i have to go
through my own [ __ ] every time with this
[ __ ] because i lived through it so i
know i said it
because remember before i ever started
talking on camera i was telling these
stories in my homies the same way like
you [ __ ] just wait till i watch this
and then the [ __ ] came outside and i
fell on her like [ __ ] like that so
that's why i can't remember everything
ready go crazy asian gangster party
that's my notes
ready yeah you just touched on the next
[ __ ] one
yeah
how crazy that was six years ago today
that happened
um
guys here we go what are we at 135 36 52
[ __ ] no
no it's not is it really
152. yeah
where is that 120
i don't [ __ ] know got in that running
danger field shot
one day we're gonna hit an hour and a
half man one day we're gonna [ __ ] do
it i promise you guys
i really thought today was a day because
i was so tired my back is
pretty much on fire like right now it
just hurts so i was like yeah there's an
hour and a half so i can go home and you
know knock some [ __ ] out
here we go crazy asian party party yeah
here we go merced predominantly mexican
mass 60 mexican 30
percent different types of like
ethnicities asian i don't know how to
say asian ethnicities
don't i'm gonna [ __ ] up and i don't know
wrong i had a lot of homies from laos
laotian fools
uh thai
thai cambodian
mong was the biggest one
wong was the biggest
long is hmong it's
i don't know where they're from i'm
sorry bro i don't know what ethnicity
that is but i know like 60 of my homies
at school were all mall
and they all had like close to the same
last name like x's and a x's and j's and
[ __ ] if i remember correctly
but
i grew up with a lot of uh you just
typed in mong and the first thing among
people yeah
[ __ ] wikipedia i hope they put the
right information all right [ __ ]
wikipedia is the first thing that pops
up that's [ __ ] it should be
something legitimate
i'm a matter of fact i'm gonna go change
this [ __ ]
like thomas is homies
just put under my people
yeah so i grew up with a lot of um asian
homies a lot a lot of asian homies and
mexican homies and [ __ ] just you know
the town's predominantly that so that's
the people you chill with that's where i
grew up
so
are you ready
i am now in 11th grade
i the the hair the long hair
selling drugs already
um
i have almost said his name i almost
[ __ ] blew someone's cover one of my
asian gangster homies uh sells pills the
guy that i talked about in the mushroom
story time when i talked about the
recent one the
mushroom trip part two or whatever i
can't remember what i called it but
magic mushrooms that one that homie that
dropped off the pills this is the same
kid
um he sold me some ecstasy
triple stacks i paid like [ __ ] it was
like 15 bucks for a pill i went damn
[ __ ]
give me it and i bought it
me and ryan you guys heard from ryan
last time i talked to ryan he sleeps
outside all right he's all [ __ ] up
he's on drugs but i did hear recently
that he went to rehab which makes me
very happy i heard that he's in rehab
and trying nice so
i'm good also which is unreal damn
almost [ __ ] choked up
joe is in rehab it has a car damn
nice yeah like he's not living outside
anymore which is really cool last i
heard
it's just weird i never i thought i was
gonna be dead i really thought he was
gonna die this year like i felt like his
mom gonna call me like [ __ ] man but no
he went to rehab oh [ __ ]
i don't want to get my hopes up we'll
just say like
joe's joe's good he's doing better so
that's really good and uh
this is the time where me and ryan were
doing ecstasy all day
any time we could we do accessing go to
a party
because it was fun
all right so me and ryan do not chill
often just me and him it's always a
group of friends for some reason this
friday night
we always had like 12 kids at ryan's and
every single person had something to do
they all went somewhere else which was
rare as [ __ ]
right
super rare
we always hang out every [ __ ] weekend
we're at nathan's house or ryan's house
so it's just me and ryan huff
and this [ __ ] tall white kid
looks just like tom petty just like time
when i first met him i go bro you know
like tom petty who is that people keep
[ __ ] telling me that he goes the
skater tom pitt no not tom penny not the
skater tom petty the guy you look like
[ __ ]
tom brady the heartbreak all right never
mind anyway
anyway that's right
and me and him were like all right i
have two pills he's like i'm gonna take
both mama i'll try both of my with you
[ __ ] yeah i took them both triple stacks
so i am [ __ ] gone
i always chewed them up i don't know why
i just like the taste of who was meth in
there i think
chewing up ecstasy pills always hits me
like in the back of my tongue
ugh
better than the drip anyway
chewing up ecstasy it gets stuck in my
teeth like sweet tarts and shocked
and every time you rub your teeth on the
tongue that grooves your teeth still
have the powder and you taste it it's
just
i love drugs oh i don't do anymore but
god i love drugs so much
and
my back just got all weird
chewed him up
and me and ryan walked
all right
we walked no no no sorry we got dropped
off at a party that's right ryan says i
heard about a party oh
what party is it because people get shot
in the face and merced i don't want to
go to those parties what street what's
on green's tree go
green in what
them
all right let's go it's an okay
neighborhood it's not as bad as a lot of
old people
let's run it let's go
got dropped off and i remember as we're
walking up as we're walking up dude i
have my mad dog 2020s two blue raspberry
one in each pocket
i'm walking up
ryan's got his drink in his pocket
we're walking up and some mexican girls
outside [ __ ] crying
hard as [ __ ]
and one of her friends is like trying to
calm her down and we're walking the door
who the [ __ ] are you guys huh who the
[ __ ] brought you guys
whoa
walk in up to the door and go whoa bro
this is a bad sign
maybe she's just drunk and got kicked
out i don't know i mean she had to fight
i don't know what's going on but i saw a
mexican girl
i'm expecting more mexican people
and i'm not saying i need to be around
making people feel safe
i just didn't know it was
my title says a lot
you guys ever seen harold and kumar
when they have to stop to buy weed
from the hippie or when they have to
stop at the school and go by that party
or something and bobby lee's there he's
like oh hello hello uh thank you tell me
about business
remember when they stop like that and
it's like only asian kids having a party
and they're [ __ ] living it up this is
not one of those
you know they were all super nice with
like button ups and doing like smoking
weed like having fun not those kind of
asian guys
this asian party i walked in was
straight true blue kids true blue is a
blue as a gang in merced i don't know
what they were mod or true blue kids but
i walked in i knocked on the door
super pretty asian girl
i'm like oh this party's cool
took a step in door closed behind me and
i went oh [ __ ]
like i literally like got my stuff and i
was walking as i walked it went
and the door closed behind me the girl
walked away and went oh we're not gonna
just
bolt out the door
but i just go
forrest gump
sorry i ruined y'all's black panther
party
that's how i felt went
[ __ ]
i don't
i don't know any mongodle oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
i walked in to a sea of blue flannels
and blue rags
i mean i walked into
[Music]
asian mods city
i have a big tall pretty white kid with
me and a little short [ __ ] mexican
long hair
i just remember like oh my [ __ ] god
sorry for everybody driving i'm just
trying to imagine everything again like
i was so [ __ ] s just bro i knew i was
gonna get shot i didn't think it was
gonna be like this and then i thought no
they're asian gangsters they're gonna
slice my ass they're not gonna shoot me
they're gonna stab me to death
it's like the [ __ ] music turned off
when i walked in
i fell that's what i felt man i walked
in and went
like you can hear me go
because there was no more music it's
like the music took a break and was
going to the next song right when i
walked in so like people were just
and when i walked you heard the door
close
and about 12 to 15 [ __ ] hard ass
looking gangbangers just
staring at me right
i could feel ryan looking at me
and i just went like that you know right
i just like
you know i don't know what's going on
and i told mike yo i don't know what's
going on right now but
and i don't remember what else i said to
him because i remember i was like [ __ ]
dude there's
they're staring right oh [ __ ] don't run
like don't run then they're gonna be
like so what the [ __ ] do you want to be
in here for [ __ ] get those what was
the point why'd you it was a gangbanger
affiliation party someone probably got
jumped the [ __ ] in that night i walked
into and it was a nice it was an okay
neighborhood but you know someone's
parents went out of town this [ __ ]
girl had everybody over that's what
happened
i walk in
these fools are all just holding [ __ ]
40s or bottles just looking
asian gangsters love hennessy to the max
so if anybody knows that i love that
there's hella hennessy everywhere
all right at least the guys i met
at least the only groups of gang asian
gangbangers i meet and drink [ __ ]
hennessy
like even the fools i know now
i won't say where but even those crazy
[ __ ]
it's
now it's 1942 but it was just bottles
and bottles balls of [ __ ] hands when
i first met him anyway
they're holding their bottles whatever
they're holding they're just i remember
the full with the [ __ ] straight
billed hat like oh
that falls 220.
that foot was [ __ ] bolo young from
bruce lee like he's gonna he's the one
who oh [ __ ] and i'm just thinking like i
know ryan can fight
i can fight too
but i don't want to get stabbed that's
all i could think i want to get stabbed
up in my hips am i right i'm done
i don't want this
and all these fools are like just stay i
know this is a long dragged but bro
i'm standing there i ca i can remember
where the house was shaped the hallway's
right here there's a wall right in front
of me so i can't see everyone in the
[ __ ] living room kitchen's right here
refrigerators hooked over here to the
right i don't know what it was but there
was a mirror right here
you go right there there's one step down
to the living room where most of the
dudes were but some of them were in the
kitchen so they were still light
so when i see them in the kitchens like
linoleum linoleum with that [ __ ] like
metal edge
one of those kind of kitchens one step
down goes the carpet
like a brick fireplace just you know
like a smaller like two to three bedroom
house
so i'm just explaining it and out right
straight at the living room was a
sliding glass door and i saw like people
smoking and [ __ ] but i couldn't see tuc
to the right so somebody could be on the
other side of the wall i didn't know and
it got me like oh [ __ ] i can't even i
don't want to do this
oh we're good i didn't want to like
i don't want these guys my girls feel
scared
and also i want them to go like at this
point scared
[Music]
i was in the no-win situation
[Laughter]
so all you guys are staring at me i can
feel ryan's like
[ __ ] i can hear it in his like
just breath or presence i can feel his
energy like bro thomas we gotta get the
[ __ ] out of here i can hear him but i
just went
yo i don't know what's going on right
now
and i i don't remember what else i said
like i said
and these fools are staring us and i
just hear
this is like 15 seconds these guys are
just looking at us and i don't want to
like sup full but i also don't want to
i'm just like [ __ ] man
what do i do
[ __ ] i have about 15 seconds in i've
never told you a story huh i just hear
thomas
question mark basically i hear thomas
and i go
yeah
i know i just a bunch of dudes i don't
know who's saying this [ __ ] like in
russia which one of y'all kicked me
that's how i felt like who said this
[ __ ] somebody knows my name who
who do i know here because i didn't see
anybody talking like
who said that i don't want to stare at
these fools in the [ __ ] eyes
so i'm like oh yo i know it came from
like over there and i just see some fool
like a knight in in into the light he
just splits these [ __ ] sea of blue
rags he goes what's up don't say his
name it's a [ __ ] kid i knew from she
he actually played basketball with every
[ __ ] day
he's a gang he chose the game bangers
now
i didn't know that i hadn't seen him
since the [ __ ] fourth grade
he just goes thomas opens that goal and
i'll say his i didn't say his name i
know his name i'm not gonna say it i say
i'm like
yo
and they're just gonna shake his hand
remember we're across the kitchen so he
has to he has to come through to see if
dudes he knows and be like no it's cool
it's cool but he goes thomas and i'm
like yo what the [ __ ] and i go i ever
seen you said fourth [ __ ] great i'm
like we were friends we used to hang out
and during recess like you won't play
basketball check out a basketball it's
good let's get one give our heart you
know you know how you go check one out
i'm in this class write your name take a
ball and me and him all day just trying
to [ __ ] do tricks
and i'm talking for five seconds and i
hear another person
thomas
and another dude comes up and it's the
dude i used to chill with in sixth grade
that we made the fake [ __ ] fighting
routine we were just [ __ ] around the
pe every day we would learn like five
more new things so by the end of the
school like
like three months in we had like a four
minute [ __ ] fake fighting routine we
would do it full [ __ ] force and never
really hit each other but it was on some
baller bruce lee should we both love
bruce lee and we [ __ ] he would high
kick and it's like all right here and
then i'm gonna duck cause you're gonna
kick
one two three four and we had like 16 18
steps
we got far but we did that full force it
looked like we were really fighting
anyway that [ __ ] walks out of
the crowd i haven't seen him since six
[ __ ] grade
he used to have my number he said stand
on your number for pe
stand in your spot for pe line up do
your stretches he was the guy behind me
yeah this guy right behind me and um
i'm like yo what the [ __ ] can i say hi
to him and then one of the gang banger
fools goes
thomas
i'm like i look at him i wasn't staring
at their faces yeah i look at him and i
still like
oh my god and i realized where i know i
was like i was a little kid he went to
she with me he was a little fat kid
just like me but i remember him like
bro
and nobody everybody went back to what
they're doing but as soon as i said hi
to the first dude they were still lying
like
nah who is this fool
second guy i wasn't even looking at them
i was so shocked like yo
do you remember the routine [ __ ]
because i don't i don't remember the
steps it's not what i asked but i was
thinking like
whoa
and then the third dude i met him and
shehee i knew him and she too he played
basketball with us and we played marbles
remember i told you with uh rick rick
ross and like marbles yeah
those are the kids i play marbles with
all right there's like i'm just amazing
kids he's playing marbles with two all
the asian kids made were hella good
those are the kids i was talking about
during that episode yeah so
i'm like yo there's no [ __ ] way
everybody just chills once i talk to the
third dude because he was one of the
gang hard looking gangbanger fools with
the flag rag hanging out his pocket
[ __ ] white cortez's
blue rag blue flannel [ __ ] straight
bill [ __ ] with the green underneath
the cap those old cheesy
had that she's just like cheap easy hats
where he used to rock like the with no
logo
generic gta gangster that's what he
looked like
and he knew me and i knew i'm like yo
this is [ __ ] crazy and then he's like
yo hold up and he goes and gets somebody
else and it's the other [ __ ] fool i
used to play marbles with too i haven't
seen these kids i was cause remember i
told you i was in the gifted classes i
had to go across [ __ ] town hmm i had
to go to the other school
remember i told you i had to leave
school
i didn't see those kids no more hmm
one trip man like what a trip they're
still in remedial [ __ ] english and
[ __ ] no we were all in the gifted
classes
oh they weren't you're right you jerk
no same ryan remedial classes that's the
same right
and uh
so
i got saved and i just stayed
so it's like 20 minutes in and we're
just taking shots now i'm chilling now
all these fools are like all right
that's cool so now we're all just taking
shots they're playing pomp beer pong
i'm like yo i'm chilling with these
crazy gangbanger [ __ ] all right
cool [ __ ] it i know these fool i know
these four guys we're good right like
i'm okay
all right cool
and uh
ryan's on ecstasy
let's get the [ __ ] out of me
so it's about 30 minutes later guys and
remember
ryan's on ecstasy
a lot of it so am i but i'm also like a
bigger fat kid and also i handle drugs
thanks mom acid brain i handle drugs
well
two those triple stacks hit me hard but
i wasn't like
jaw going nothing like that ryan was
geeking
he was on one remember merced pills are
cut with meth they're never full mdma
excessives never that
so ryan's on one and i can see it in his
face like he is
on one
he is dancing with this really pretty
asian girl he's dancing with her and i'm
like damn ryan's getting aggressive he's
like [ __ ] going at it right
mac dre had just died and the wave was
hard in merced for ecstasy
everybody wanted this thizzles x's euros
triples
and uh
i'm sitting there with my drinks and
elizal randomly a light which doesn't
live far lives have been many story
times he just pops up out of nowhere
and eliza's on ecstasy too and he's
drunk as [ __ ] and he's just in the party
out of nowhere i'm like oh
how do you awesome one of my homies i
live down the street i know you live
down the street that's why i came here i
thought it was a cool place like oh
elizabeth's over there it's not a bad
neighborhood so i walk into this place
and out of nowhere because i'm [ __ ] up
eliza's just there i'm like oh
this is tight so it's only like 30
minutes in right i'm in the dark like
living room where everybody's like
chilling or dancing it's like it's a
house party kitchen's lit up every
taking shots but you can see the kitchen
from the living room
so
ryan dancing with the asian girl
aggressive
and then a bunch of people i'm talking
to one of the dudes that i knew from
playing marbles
and you know he goes back with his
homies and i'm just sitting there at
that point we got the okay to like just
be there
i was coming to a [ __ ] house party
that's what you did in high school
that's what we do in high school you
just show up at the [ __ ] house party
that's all you're supposed to do that
nobody gets out flyers this isn't
[ __ ]
every 10 things i hate about you and
[ __ ] like doesn't there's no flyers
unless your parents have expendable
[ __ ] income all right not over here
anyway
elijah's just randomly there he's [ __ ]
[ __ ] up he might have been there the
whole time i just didn't know but it was
a dark living remember i said but you
can see the porch light in the back on
where people were smoking too
so it's like remember that like door lit
up kitchen dark ass living room lit up
porch people smoking so i go outside and
i have a blunt i'm still smoking blunts
i have a blood i'm selling weed at the
time i have a blunt i light the blown up
i come outside and the prettiest asian
girl that brian was talking to
she's on ecstasy too
and she comes out and i can see like
damn your eyes are black
and she's just glistening sweaty
nose ring iron was like dance girls
hella pretty this is
good job right
and i was like
damn you're sweaty she got close to me
she was talking oh my god please back up
girl you are dripping sweat
i'd get away from you that's all i
thought like oh
i could do this
to you like [ __ ] back up you were
dancing hard in there with that [ __ ]
ecstasy ridden white kid
and she starts talking she's like yo
yo what's your name i'm like
the way she was talking i'm like [ __ ]
aren't you like dancing on my homie wait
talking to me
like that and she's talking so where you
from i'm like oh okay cool she's kind of
she's in the house full of gang banger
she's not a preppy [ __ ] she's a she's
kind of down you can see it like
the way she's talking like oh i know
your time
not for me
because your brother is probably in
there
and uh she goes you gotta tell your
homie to chill out i go i know sorry
he's all [ __ ] up he's dancing hardship
no no like it's cool but like
he's like getting too like aggressive i
go oh my bad he's like
yeah you like
yo no matter what i've told the story
many times i can't get through it
without
sorry
she's she's [ __ ] obsessed
he's so aggressive i go i know i'm sorry
she goes yeah
he's pushing his boner in my back
right it's like six three he's a little
short asian girl he's like
all on drugs he's like yeah he's pushing
his boner into my back he has to chill
brian's inside jaw going in circles
doesn't realize he's just try humping
this girl in front of the [ __ ]
hillside tracy from training day
the way she said it because she's caught
like
when your parents don't speak english
like a lot of mexican fools you still
have that accent with mexican people you
know what i'm talking about you still
have like that accent because you speak
spanish daily you i don't know i i see
that a lot
same with asian people when they're when
they're when they're the first like
american born people like they translate
for their parents you can hear like
their accent still kind of like there's
a lot of my homies you hear everyone
everyone that doesn't speak english
first still has the accent somewhat
the way she's popping his boner in my
back the way she said it just made me
like bro shut the [ __ ] up i want to
laugh in your face
i was like oh yeah i'll tell them to
chill like yeah i know i was like okay
she's like oh can i hit that like oh
oh i don't know you
how many boners you got yeah how many
boners got shoved in your face
and then
she started cheating on me bro right
then and they're like so what's up man
like oh hey where are you from like well
you want to do some [ __ ] and my whole
time like
i'm sorry but your profuse sweating's
got me like i gotta get the work away
from you i don't even want to be i did
i was on drugs i'm over here just
analyzing it
no
no
get away from me
anyway she's talking about yo i'm be
inside and i just cut it off let her
keep like a little less than half the
blood like finish this i'll be right
back i'm gonna get ryan i just lie i'm
like going back inside it's two steps
away i'm going back inside i want
nothing to do with it i don't know
getting involved was [ __ ] she was
hella pretty but
no gangster families for me yeah and i
go in and i'm like yo ron what's up i'm
like yo that girl straight up told me
that you got to chill he goes what what
i do i told him what she said he goes
oh my bad
he was like embarrassing oh my my bad he
like looked down i'm like this yeah it's
loud it's a house part i'm in his ear
she's that she pushes your boner in her
back
oh oh my
bad and the way he said like yo this is
amazing we stayed there for i can't
remember how long
and we walked
i don't remember
we might we had to walk back to ryan's
i don't there's no way we drove for some
reason i feel like we drove
but if i walked up straight to the house
there's no way we would have parked back
there
i think we [ __ ] drove no i guys for
one of the first times i can't fully
remember
if i can't remember clearly i'm not
gonna say it's definite we got we drove
we got dropped off but when we left i
don't i could have swore we drunkenly
walked home
and i remember walking down the key but
that could have been any night
wow it's a story time first i can't be
definite i'm pretty positive we walked
the [ __ ]
home but that was it crazy asian game
surprise i hope you guys [ __ ] walked
home that was scared
i i don't i don't ever get the car
people drink and drive but i would
remember that yeah i've only done it
once i only drove a little buzzed once
and i remember driving going this is
[ __ ] stupid
i wasn't [ __ ] up but i remember like
this is dumb why are you doing this bro
this
off of green street
six years later after that when i was
like 22 off of green street i drove a
little bit buzz from my homie anthony's
birthday back to my house in merced
weird but yeah uh crazy education party
nothing to do with crazy rich asians the
[ __ ] show
um
quite the opposite quite the opposite
but the reason i bring it up because
i've been around so many of the gangs
mod
the dead end park was the mod land when
i was a kid i never walked through there
all the fools were long no hair on the
side
long ass [ __ ] hair wearing all the
blue the asian fools that wear really
really clean white tees do not [ __ ]
go near them those are the guys that
will kill you
always
i always say like yo the scariest
[ __ ] gangsters ever are asian food
asian fools because they will come 35
deep and kill you
some of mexicans
but like bro i can talk like if you
don't like i don't know what it is it's
like those fools are scary as [ __ ]
they're serious at least the ones that
are sad they're [ __ ] serious they
will shoot [ __ ] rosy sister got shot
in the [ __ ] head by one of these guys
damn she lived through it but my cousin
adrian some crazy [ __ ] happened there
their whole [ __ ] car got showed up
and really just got shot the [ __ ]
head i remember when that [ __ ] happened
i was with my uncle john i was smoking
weed with him and we went back into his
living room off 24th street 21st street
and then rose just called me and just
here screaming and then all this [ __ ]
it's a long story
but it was crazy asians crazy asian
[ __ ] game bangers
people are probably out there is this
guy racist like no i'm saying i would
have said crazy mexicans yeah we've
touched on all different crazy black
guys i would have said the same [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's just these guys are crazy they just
saw my my cousin adrian has a red
red or blue i can't remember it was a
red or blue honda little honda like
a little racer one
brother he left burger king he saw them
in the [ __ ] in the store
in the restaurant they got their food
walked out he said they went down the
street got to the stop sign these fools
were [ __ ] rolled up and sprayed their
entire [ __ ] car
for nothing
they didn't do [ __ ]
but yeah rosie said gonna [ __ ] shot
in the head jesus christ crazy my cousin
didn't get shot though but i remember i
remember that that night was [ __ ]
insane
everything about that night was crazy
it was a trip
um
yeah
there it is
i don't think you get that in a lot of
cities in america
she got shot in the head for real i got
shot in the head with a homemade gun
have we talked we haven't talked about
that on here yeah we have there we go
okay there we go yeah that hurt i wonder
how bad that hurt
ugh
anyway dangerous dangerous games trying
to live your life
dangerous you know just living around
pieces of [ __ ]
seriously
i don't mind gangbang as long as i shoot
each other just don't shoot people that
have nothing to do with anything because
then it's like bro
how is this fair
say a fair game at that point like i got
to be careful for everybody
it's a reason i don't take your [ __ ]
with your money yeah because i don't
want any part of what you do
if i [ __ ] with your money then shoot at
me that's fine
i don't know it get pisses me the [ __ ]
off i'm sure
how long are we in i'm gonna say 210
yeah right around there 20.
[ __ ]
all right
pretty fair
first couple episodes you were 152.
i was on it huh oh what's going on
these last two three episodes i've been
[ __ ]
you know what it's been we've been
starting it and i've been [ __ ] up the
intro earlier today
the first intro we did today as i went
what a [ __ ] plane flow flies over
loud as [ __ ]
we gotta get that sealed
well you know what doesn't matter we're
yeah it doesn't matter anymore we're
[ __ ] moving man yeah
i'm gonna start pumping in the plane
sound effects the train just to keep it
a reminder
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
i'm good
um
yeah guys thank you so much for hanging
out it's another two hours it's [ __ ]
another day it's past midnight now we've
been here for 12 [ __ ] hours painting
and doing everything oh yeah
all right
i'm with it
i love it [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] love it
tomorrow i'm gonna get up tomorrow i'm
filming the duct tape challenge
oh
part three
[ __ ] except this time
the trilogy except this time
i know what my mistakes were
i have to eat and drink something first
that's what i'm gonna do today i'm gonna
eat and drink something first
all right
and i'm going to kill two [ __ ] grand
pods on my hands
edward 40 hands you duct tape 40s to
your hands drink them i do with vape
pens
and i smoke them until they're gone and
tomorrow i'm going to studio motors
and
oh you know what let me not talk about
it this video will be out before
the duct tape challenge video duct tape
challenge video comes out next thursday
tomorrow comes out story time so this is
the plan guys every monday is the
podcast we try to do every single monday
at five
i think
just throwing it out there
i think we should start doing it
slightly earlier
because monday night football i just
realized that monday night football's on
and dudes i want to watch the game yeah
you got to do something i don't want to
watch the game
competing with that either
i just that too i just sometimes like
yell
you guys let us know what do you want
yeah what do you guys want what do you
guys want we just adjust for monday at
football because you know it does [ __ ]
up people's timing some people don't
want to watch
the pockets they can watch after and
just watch mine inevitable i totally get
it yeah i agree with you
we'll figure that out i'll figure it out
yeah
i thought about it the other day
like
what did that football's on i just i was
like thursday night football is [ __ ]
weird i'm like
we're competing with monday night
[ __ ] football
on the premiere
i'll look back and go soon
i also have the football game on when
i'm all right it's in the background i'm
listening but we're sitting there typing
it's it's impossible to really watch the
game just typing the whole time but
monday every monday is a new episode all
right
every monday news up new episode sunday
night at midnight so basically right
when it turns monday audio's up usually
yeah usually we're trying but after the
house is done bro yeah yeah yeah at that
point because before we went into the
house we were like two days ahead yeah
three days ahead of the podcast bro you
have so much to do so you're building a
house so
it's it's a given
so sunday night at midnight basically
monday morning at 12 a.m audio goes out
so if you're driving to work for if
you're listening right now and you're
driving to work remember you do not have
to wait for the premiere you can go with
spotify apple podcast google podcast
all the all the podcast platforms run
all of them or i'm like [ __ ] 15 of
them
you can listen to the episode when you
drive to work you don't have to wait you
do not have to wait till the uh episode
premieres on youtube
episode will always premiere youtube
later because i'm not posting at [ __ ]
seven in the morning
the [ __ ] no i wanna post some people are
alive and awake and [ __ ] right not just
on their way to work
so monday's the podcast this is what i'm
trying to do i'm trying to have it to
where every single month monday no
matter what podcast is there
every thursday dopaziola channel every
single thursday from now on is my
posting day i want to start posting
every single thursday because
when you're at school and you get off on
a thursday isn't it [ __ ] awesome
because you know you just gotta go to
sleep
wake up one more time
go to school every period is like i
don't give a [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] i
don't care [ __ ] i'll deal with it
monday that's how i feel every single
thursday night
so that's why i want to give people the
feeling of like oh
thursday i'm off for school month for
work new video nice and then leads your
ass into [ __ ] friday have a good
weekend that's how and monday sucks dick
sometimes for people so that's why we
post pockets of money see people react
to that yeah because sometimes like yo i
need to start my [ __ ] week off right
and that's why we do it monday thursday
is for me because i always think of like
thursday nights where the [ __ ]
is friday morning i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm tired wake up i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm going to sleep when i get home i
never did but you know yeah i like to
think that i could yeah yeah right i did
that [ __ ] this morning i did that this
[ __ ] morning i had to be up in like
six seven [ __ ] hours yeah in this
video but uh
here we go
every thursday dope is your video
story time comes out tomorrow really
stoked about this one high school part
two
um
story time i mean thursday dopa's yolo
videos guys right
and every friday this is my new goal
adventures of viola video
adventures of yolo channel every friday
because i'm going to edit goddamn i'm
going to edit on monday and tuesday
before the podcast starts i'll have
monday tuesday to edit throw it to you
tuesday the adventures of yolo channels
the edits aren't crazy
yet
it gives you what wednesday thursday
friday
correct
and
the episode i filmed i might i film my
film days for dopaziola's thursday so
why am i talking about the [ __ ]
schedule on here i'm i'm done
i'm sorry i'm going to you're good
you're letting the fans know what get
out yeah no this is good
yeah bro we're not on facetime i got to
stop [ __ ] thinking like we're on
facetime i'm sorry guys
[ __ ]
sorry you're going to be releasing the
dope as yolo videos on the more regular
every thursday dope zola video every
monday is the dope's usual podcast every
friday hopefully i'm trying right now
the adventures yes but
if i film on friday or i film on monday
and i get it to you tuesday yeah there
wednesday thursday friday morning
schedule is everything perfect just
three full days to do a quick edit bomb
yeah but i film on thursday dopaziola
and i get that [ __ ] too hopefully
friday night set etc and then monday
whatever it starts
monday tuesday wednesday that's [ __ ]
realistically
three or four business days
no weekend [ __ ] whatsoever i'm trying to
maybe like we don't need it on monday
anymore we don't need to post on monday
to open your channel because then you're
like scrambling and your whole weekend
is not even there
trying to make it towards like oh it's
friday we're done cool monday right back
[ __ ] exactly yeah but i mean i'm
still doing [ __ ] on the weekend but
that's different it's like filming and
editing that's
my schedule but that's what i'm trying
to do so there's three uploads a week
i'm just trying my best
it's [ __ ] it's a great call yeah
three uploads a week man
and every story time i want it to be a
bonus so there's always four videos
every thursday one every thursday plus
two story times so six videos a month
there you go that's our cue that's my
cue to get the [ __ ] out of here sorry
for rambling but for everyone out there
that runs businesses you guys can
totally relate to what the [ __ ] me and
him are talking about this whole episode
this whole episode is all about [ __ ]
business
tcb all right
all right guys
[ __ ] you train thank you guys so much
for watching
we're not going to be hearing that [ __ ]
very much longer i'm so excited
guys
thank you so much this is episode 35
right yup wow crazy
we've said goodbye 35 times on this show
okay
i'm getting a little stronger too it's
coming up episode 100
i'm gonna hit that pull up
the other day i got on there and hung
for a minute so i went
all right okay and i tried to pull up
and i straightened my whole arm the
whole [ __ ] shoulder
died
and we'll see um guys thank you so much
for watching before you get out of here
do us a favor if you are on youtube and
watching leave a [ __ ] like on
the channel it really helps share it
with a homie share it on your page
whatever you want to do leave a comment
all right always leave a comment and
just drop who do you want to see on the
show that's the best way of us writing
on our guest list the best way of us
getting more guest side because
sometimes you guys drop names i'll text
more you're like wrong great idea how do
we not think about this person you guys
have no idea how many of your comments
are in my notebook
truly i've written down whoever [ __ ]
suggested bill nye the science guy he
wrote i talked about him today i want
bill nye the science guy on here big
time it's from a fan a fan actually dm'd
it to me and i went oh good [ __ ] oh no
it's a comment there's a comment drop a
comment who do you want to see or if you
want to say what up thank you guys so
much for watching thank you for
supporting us
i wanted to get into it but
big time sponsorship [ __ ] happening
let's leave it at that very happy very
stoked
surreal as [ __ ] thank you guys so much
for watching
uh best way you can ever support the
podcast the best way ever tell a homie
tell a friend share a link
best thing you could do thank you guys
so much for watching marty thank you
guys we really appreciate it
i just realized i haven't had my
invisalign in all day um my teeth just
shifted when i went party god i felt my
teeth like oh my god
sorry
marty
oh god
oh that just made my whole back cringe
when you said my teeth shifted bro my
whole background's when i thought about
eating excess teeth in my teeth
my whole back shivered
um we appreciate you guys
thank you for all your support we're
doing our best here
oh man i [ __ ] love drugs pick it up a
couple notches yeah
yeah season two i can already see the
set ferngully colors here we go guys
thank you so much for watching this has
been another episode of the dope as
usual podcast from marty drastic
graphics and i
thank you so much for watching i am
dobaziola
have a dope ass day
i'm i'm high man i'm high and motivated
which is like the best combination
do i have pain in my hair still
perfect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]